Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit den Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten,
mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer längeren Pause begrüße ich alle wieder hier die Lust haben auf Raumfahrt und die anderen Angelegenheiten.
Ja und ich habe mir auch gleich einen schönes neues Thema ausgesucht was gut in die Zeit passt wie festgestellt habe Termin vorher geplant und dann wurde man schon wieder von den Nachrichten,
der Welt überrollt heute sonst gehen um schwarze Löcher und dazu bin ich nach Bonn gefahren zum Max-Planck-Institut für Radioastronomie.
Und spreche dem Direktor nehme ich Michael Kramer für guten Tag.
Ja Kramer hier wurde wir werden dann auch gleich noch mal bisschen drauf eingehen bisschen wissenschafts Weltgeschichte geschrieben nicht nur hier sondern an vielen Orten rund um die welt schwarze Löcher sind gerade mal wieder,
das Gespräch in den wissenschaftlichen Fluren und darüber hinaus.
Untergrund ca dieses Thema mal aufzunehmen aber nicht der einzige denn,
gehört ja auch so ein bisschen zu diesem mythischen Objekten habe ich so den Eindruck immer wenn es um Raumfahrt und Weltall geht.
Bevor wir darauf kommen würde ich aber ganz gern noch mal hinterfragen wie sie eigentlich dazu gekommen sind was hat sie denn in die Wissenschaft getrieben und was hat sie vor allem in diesem Bereich getrieben.
Hast du noch nie das zugesagt hat mich schon immer fasziniert als Kind ich,
indem ich z.b. hatte ein Buch da war Effelsberg vorne auf dem Titelbild drauf da wusste ich noch gar nicht dass das ein Teleskop in der Eifel ist und ich hatte zum Glück einen wunderbaren Physiklehrer der Hals den ganzen Leistungskurs Physik den ich gewählt hatte,
unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Astrophysik gestellt hat und so bin ich halt mehr Männer Thema reingerutscht und,
dann als Folge dessen auch Physik studiert in Köln aber immer mit der Absicht später halt in die Astrophysik zu gehen wobei mich.
Nie so sehr muss ich gestehen die Astronomie als solche sondern mal wer die Physik dahinter interessiert hat weniger also wie die Sterne aussehen sondern vielmehr wieder funktionieren.
Untermauern so bin ich dann über meine Diplomarbeit hier.
Amewi für Radiochemie gelandet und habe noch eine Doktorarbeit hier gemacht über unsere und Neutronensterne und so bin ich dann auch in das Gebiet der Karte zu uns Forschung gerutscht und ja das ist ja fein mein Haupt Arbeitsgebiete hiermit.
Aber warum warum dieses Gebiet nicht irgendein anderes Mal Mann gibt ja dann ein weites Feld wie kommt man dazu.
Mellis war eher ein Zufall wie ich jetzt zum Thema Neutronenstern und Pulsar gekommen bin,
einfach weil damals ein Diplomand gesucht wurde der Computerkenntnisse hatte und Daten die mit Effelsberg aufgenommen wurden auswerten kommt oder wollte,
so bin ich halt in der Truhen Stelle reingerutscht und Pulsar bieten immer noch die genauesten testerwelt evidenztheorie in starken Optionsfeldern,
immer noch genauer als weico oder jetzt mit dem Bilder Schwarzen Lochs zugesehen
ist der Schritt vom Sog von Hipp Präzisionstechnik radiation bis hin zu Studien der anderen Objekte mit der Gase starken Kaffee zu uns Feldern und unser kleiner Schritt und,
Passau zusammen unter der ist der Titel meiner Arbeitsgruppe hier leider lautet auch Radio aus dem Radio astronomische fundamental Physik was wir also wirklich versuchen,
mit Radioastronomie als nahezu perfekten Werkzeug versuchen die Grundgesetze der Physik insbesondere der Grad der Schwerkraft hat zu verstehen.
Wie ist das Institut denn so vernetzt also mit wem arbeitet man zusammen hier stehen keine Antennen rum wo kriegt man seine Daten her.
Nee unser behaupte Arbeitswerte steht immer noch eine Eifel das 100 m Teleskop in Auftrag Effelsberg nach Franz Pütz Bad Münstereifel.
Ist immer noch das größte Teleskop in Europa das zweitgrößte Frage wirkliche Teleskop der Welt,
nur Tropfen für mit 103m Formeln Green Bank telescope in den USA und jetzt hat sich ganz neu das 500 Meter Teleskop in China fast dass ich allerdings nicht bewegen kann sondern Talsohle eingebaut ist sozusagen,
unterm Effelsberg ist als hochleistungsteleskop 2,
mit 50 Jahren praktisch eine gute alte Dame aber immer noch sehr auf den neuesten Stand es wird immer wie weiter verbessert es ist so gut wie.
Und das überhaupt Teleskop für betreiben aber auch als Institut und das Apex List Coop in Chile der Nähe von Alma.
Das ist besonder auch beim Bild des Schwarzen Lochs vor ein paar Wochen halt entsprechende wenn Notwendigkeit hatte dabei zu sein.
Wir arbeiten aber auch sehr eng mit dem ihrem Teleskop dem Teleskop für Miniaturen wieder zu Astronomie in Frankreich in Grenoble zusammen wo wir Teleskope halt auch in Spanien haben,
das ist windig in der Schwester Institut als solches wird von MPG wenn man Gesellschaft auch erzählte finanziert.
Und damit also mit diesem Teleskop Bereich haben wir sehr enge Verbindung aber dann sind wir endlich auch weltweit mit andern Teleskopen vernetzt in Europa,
in der ganzen Welt und ein Radio aus tonium waren immer diejenigen die schon während des Kalten Krieges sozusagen über Ländergrenzen und Blog Grenzen hinweg international zusammengearbeitet haben.
Können Radioteleskope überall stehen auf der Erde ist das eine egal wo man die platziert.
Das Schöne ist dass Reisegruppe im Prinzip überall bei jedem Wetter Tag und Nacht beobachten können es ist nur eine Frage der Beobachtungs Frequenz,
wie gut der stand auch dann für ihre jeweilige Wissenschaft ist er Felsberg da wo warten wir es von nils niedrige Frequenzen bis ungefähr 100 Gigahertz.
Dann ist er den Verstand aufgrund des Wetters und der Wolken die damit verbunden sind halt nicht ideal,
immer zu hohen Frequenzen geht dann dämpft der Wasserdampf in der Atmosphäre das Signal sehr,
dann muss man halt so höhere gelegenen Orten gehen wie auf Bergspitzen wo daneben der Rest der Atmosphären wesentlichen kleiner ist und um 0:30 Uhr Unempfindlichkeit hat bei hohen Frequenzen.
Also im Extremfall Atacama-Wüste vor fast keine Feuchtigkeit ist.
Wemfall genau oder so zeigen dass du der beste stand auch dafür dass ich dir Südpol als trockenste Gegend der der Welt sozusagen weil da die ganze der ganze Wasserdampf hat aus gefroren ist und die Lou.
Aber das nur theoretisch da gibt's kein Radioteleskop oder doch.
Doch es gibt ein Reiter Südpol Teleskop gibt's da das unter anderen von Kollegen aus den USA betrieben wird und das war auch am eventuellen Teleskop maßgeblich.
Okay und das nicht sehr widrige Bedingungen unter denen man dort so ein Gerät betreiben muss.
Das ist wohl wahr das bedingt auch die entsprechenden Leute die dann bereit sind da 6 Monate die zu überwintern und das ist gut zu betreiben.
Aber auf die Daten selbst rauszubekommen also ein ein Teil der Daten vom Südpol Teleskop z.b.
Kann man mit Verzögerung erst nach Bonn weil eben die das Ausfliegen der Festplatten die Daten drauf gespeichert waren eben warten musste bis der Frühling in der Antarktis wieder.
So gesehen ja dass das planen und das Betreiben ist es Coop dort unten ist schon sehr.
Also wie viele sind das around the world.
8h also 8 mm Teleskop mm Bild des Schwarzen Loches mitgewirkt Radius, solches gibt's sehr viel mehr auf der Welt wie gesagt es hängt von der Frequenz aber der sie beobachten wollen.
Kette des großen Opas Effelsberg wir haben aber noch vier weitere große Disco Band Europa wir haben z.b.
Nassläufer Teleskop insolvent in England Nähe von Manchester wo ich auch zehn Jahre lang gearbeitet habe,
das Wetter ist auch nicht so toll es wäre auch kein idealer Standort führen ein optisches Teleskop aber als Radioteleskop das in Zentimeter Wellenlängenbereich arbeitete ist es sehr gut geeignet,
wir haben noch transit-it's Gruppe das irgendwann seine Nähe von Union es ist 100m Gesamtfläche kann sich aber wenig bewegen.
Dann haben wir noch das 64m Teleskop in Sardinien.
Was heißt transit.
Das ist ein einstellen der Spiegel ist ein Wesen im ganzen interessante Fantasie sein der Spiegel steht,
dich senkrecht und sie haben einen Umlenkspiegel der dann sozusagen die Strahlung vom Himmel auf diesen senkrecht gestellte Spiegel umlenken und dann doch detektiert,
und das ist hat hat eine Gesamtfläche von ungefähr umgerechnet,
100 m Teleskop ist aber wie gesagt weil der Spiegel Fest senkrecht steht nicht bewegt blaseneingang Spiegel kann man hin und her bewegen und alles kann man eine Quelle für höchstens im 23 Stunden ja ein zwei Stunden verfolgen,
wann hat bei Effelsberg Bothmann Halti hat die Mutti Sterkrade am Himmel sichtbar ist praktisch kontinuierlich beobachten kann wenn er.
Das billiger.
Ist es billiger gewesen das damals zu bauen claranet frei bewegliche Teleskop ist immer sehr viel aufwendiger keine besondere wenn es eine Größe hat wie Effelsberg wo dann die Deformationen der Schwerkraft,
eben versucht das Teleskop aus der optimalen parolin Form zu zu diffamieren.
Und erste geniale Tricks von von Hachenberg und Kollegen Effelsberg und diesen procito Homologie zu bauen wo die Rücken Struktur das discope sich verformen lässt,
aber in einer vordefinierten in bestimmten Arten Weise das immer wieder ein paar barabu Lied rauskommt dass man im Prinzip nur den Fokus nachführen muss.
Andere Teleskope zB dass er dienen Testgruppe eventtage oder auch das,
größere Teleskop in greenbank die versuchen dieser Deformation der Schwerkraft mit Aktuatoren entgegenzuwirken so dass man praktisch die Paneele entsprechend stellen.
Aber das führt häufig zu Fehlerquellen Ball mit jedem Aktuator von der potentielle Fehlerquelle,
und haben somit auch die Sacktuch Aktuatoren beim TV TR eben auch nicht dauernd benutzt und dann nur zum verstellen zwischen den Beobachtungen nicht kontinuierlich.
An den Gardinen hatte man das Disco piska,
Anja stillstehen wann man die Aktuatoren austauschen musste so gesehen dass das Prinzip der Homologie was in Effelsberg hat angewendet wurde ist schon recht genial,
Tattoos wir eine praktisch optimale Form jeweils haben ohne halt die die anzahl Fehlerquellen zu erhöhen.
Und der neue Ansatz der Chinesen also arbeiten Sie mit den Chinesen auch zusammen mit dem fast oder.
Ja wir haben ja gerne eine Kollaboration mit den Chinesen mittlerweile angefangen weil die halt die,
groß Empfindlichkeit haben aber halt weil es ihnen im Tal fest montiert ist können Sie praktisch nur den Teil den sie sich von diesem tescom ausleuchten bestimmen dem sie auch wiederum zur Zeit den Fokus hin und her bewegen.
Dir das ist richtig langsam möglich aufgrund der Struktur aber die so groß ist.
Wir hingegen sind wir und teleskoplöffel schneller agiler und flexibler,
das heißt was wir jetzt machen z.b. wenn sie suchen jetzt war ich für nach poolsana Neutronenstern und wir können die dann viel flexible mit dem Effelsberg Teleskop nachverfolgen bestätigen als solltest,
die Quellen real sind und zum anderen auch dann anfangen die Welt zu vermessen und die Wissenschaft auch raus zu extrahieren und so haben wir eine enge Kollaboration und.
Diddy diddy bei der Gruppe sind da wunderbar komplementär und daher eben diese eine Cholera.
Also es gibt
viele Radioteleskope nicht alle haben dieselben Eigenschaften verschiedene Eigenschaften Tauben für unterschiedliche Beobachtungs Kanarien je nachdem ob man hier schnell reagieren muss oder ob Sie um eine dauerhafte Beobachtungen
geht also ich denke mir so etwas wie die jüngste beobachtete
Kollision zweier Neutronensterne die er diese zweite große Gravitationswellen Detektion oder II besonders beobachtete Gravitationswellen Beobachtung ausgelöst hat
das war ja im Prinzip so einen Moment wo das rote Telefon klingelt und gesagt wird hier.
Alle mal da bitte hinschauen da passiert gerade was wir müssen da was bestätigen dann kommt Susan Effelsberg zum Einsatz.
Richtig wäre mit FSB Optik weil auch drauf geschaut und wir sind in dem Verbund gewesen das halt diese vorab Nachrichten vertraulich zugesandt bekommen hat,
und wir sind dementsprechend dann auch in Essen Tagen nach der Kollision entsprechend Teleskop auf die Quelle gefahren haben geschaut was wir sehen können.
Im Radiobereich ist es so dass wir das Signal nicht direkt erwarten mit der Kollision sondern weil die Radiowellen werden sich erst aus dem dichten Plasma das bei der Explosion entstanden ist sich Vorarbeiten bis nur zu sagen dass wenn,
sein direktes uns auch sich ausdehnt wo wir doch die Plasmadichte kleine und damit können eventuell auch die Radio Quellen Radio werden raus,
just na das wird sofort nicht sehen kann aber wir haben dann relativ schnell zügig nachgeschaut und.
Sind damit auch auf der Landkarte gewesen Teleskope die dorthin geschaut haben,
mittlerweile hat leider wieder angefangen zu beobachten diesmal sind die Träger wie wir sie nennen öffentlich das heißt die Anzahl Teleskope die sich mit der Nachverfolgung dieser pulsions Produkte beschäftigen wird wird noch größer werden als vom letzten Mal.
Leygo ist dieses amerikanische gravitationswellendetektor System 2 Installation USA mittlerweile ist ja noch III in Italien glaube ich das.
Französisch italienischer Bürgerprojekte Nähe von Pisa genau.
Das heißt jetzt kann man ja,
dreidimensionale nachvollziehen woher eine Gravitationswelle kommt wenn sie denn empfangen wird ist denn da jetzt viel los also klingt jetzt hier jeden Tag das Telefon und hier ist neu Gravitationswelle schaut mal rein oder es ist nachher selten.
Also wir kriegen die Direktionen per E-Mail geschickt,
und erinnert HZI die Mailbox quält momentan über weil dies Kandidaten die nicht unbedingt real sind aber es gibt halt mit dem Träger halt gemeldet werden und,
ja mal so die Anzahl der E-Mails in letzten Wochen erheblich angestiegen.
Gleich okay also die neue Technologie die falls auf jeden Fall ganz ordentlich
ich hatte ja hier bei Raumzeit jüngst auch ein Gespräch über
nur Drohnen Sterne das war dann auch genau eine Woche bevor die große nachricht rauskam dass erstmalig diese Kollision von 20 Truhen Stern dann tatsächlich der diktiert wurde darüber.
Jetzt sind wir ein bisschen ein ganz klein bisschen hinterher weil die letzten vier Wochen waren hier recht unterhaltsam könnte ich mir vorstellen sonst du schon 4 Wochen fast gar nicht.
22 glaube ich ja ja.
Genau ich spreche natürlich von der Veröffentlichung des Bildes von foto mit Hirt man nicht sprechen eines Schwarzen Lochs vielleicht kommen wir meist mal auch auf dieses Thema.
Jetzt haben wir es ja dem Weltall mit einer sehr komplexen Struktur zu tun.
Und vielleicht mal so bisschen mit den Begriffen hier von vorne rein bisschen Überblick zu schaffen also wir sind ja hier.
In unserer Galaxie und diese Galaxie ist wiederum mit vielen anderen Galaxien zusammen in Clustern zusammengefasst je nachdem wie weit man da schaut kann man immer größere Gesamtstrukturen beobachten.
Die größte Struktur die derzeit so erkannt wird dieses wunderschöne Wort laniakea.
Also zwar nur einen einen einen mega Verbund von verschiedenen galaxiencluster indem man wohl irgendwie ansehen kann dass ihr alle was miteinander zu tun haben also sie bewegen sich zueinander konform
das alles schon ziemlich unvorstellbar aber jetzt gibt's ja auch noch so bestimmte Bereiche die sehr unverstanden sind.
Und ich hätte gar nicht mal nur von dunkler Materie und dunkle Energie waren eben von diesem schwarzen Löchern.
Ist das ein bisschen so ein mythisches Ding auch was es gibt sowieso ein paar Begriffe die schaffen es immer wieder auch so in die Populärkultur und inspirieren die Leute füttern die schwarzen Löcher gehören definitiv dazu.
Seit wann weiß man denn überhaupt dass es etwas was man so nennen könnte.
Die ersten Überlegungen dazu sind schon recht alt ist von den 17 Jahrhundert gab es halt Überlegungen ob es einen Stern gibt der,
so viel Masse hat das eben nicht den ich hinkommen kann.
Das ganze wurde dann halt sehr viel konkreter als wir dann mit einstandsparty betätigte zum ersten Mal auch die entsprechenden Rechnungen machen konnten keine Klasse ich diese Rechte ganz sicher durchführen dass man Inhalte nicht Masse bekommt wohl dann die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit.
Größer ist als der C Lichtgeschwindigkeit A-Klasse ich gesehen ist dieses diese pro Stunde so noch gibt was die nächsten kommen kann nicht so überraschend aber.
Aber ich finde es ein bisschen überraschend dass diese Vorstellung das Licht auch der Gravitation unterliegt ist doch eigentlich relativ.
Nee die die findet man teilweise schon im 17. jahrhundert also das ist jetzt nicht vielleicht in der Aller Endgültigkeit am Ende durchdacht worden,
aber einzelne Personen haben in der Tat diese Vorstellung sollte schon.
Auch Lichtablenkung an der Sonne ist hier kann man Klasse ich rechnen kann man alte wichtig rechnen ist wann haben Faktor 2 Unterschied,
aber das ist jetzt da wenn man einmal die den Schritt gemacht hat das Masse und Energie Erkelenz,
da kann man ja Tat halt eben auch die Anziehungskraft höre auf das Licht entsprechend aussehen.
Aber es ist richtig dass natürlich die die die Beschreibung wie sie heute haben,
erst mit der allgemeinen Validität Theorie zu uns gekommen ist.
Aber das heißt dass das quasi die die Vorstellung dieses schwarzen Loch war einfach eine theoretische Überlegung so.
Etwas was viel Masse hat hat eine große Anziehungskraft wenn sich das immer weiter steigert was passiert dann das ist so langweilig die die theoretische Frage mit dem man sich erstmal beschäftigt hat.
So ärgern wenn man wenn man weiß dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit endlich ist und wenn man weiß dass,
von Anita Körper nieder Masse eine bestimmte Fluchtgeschwindigkeit hat dann ist er der nächste Schritt zu überlegen was passiert wenn diese Fluchtgeschwindigkeit,
die man braucht größer ist als die Geschwindigkeit des Lichts dann ist man am Prinzip schon bei dem Konzept eines Schwarzen Lochs dabei.
Wie gesagt die die die Konsequenzen als solches wurden halt vielleicht nicht bis zu Ende gedacht und weil auch die Theorie hat dazu nicht da war.
Und dann die halt jetzt so ist halt.
Entsprechend anders als die klassische Physik dadurch dass die galation halt nicht einfachen instantane Kraft ist die zwischen zwei Massen Herbst und es ist vielmehr Ausdruck der der Raumkrümmung die durch die Massen hat sorgt wird.
Und diese berühmte Satzteil die Masse sagt dem Raum wir gegründet zu der Raumzeit und,
Gründer Roms heute,
zeig eigentlich dass wir bei der Konzeption nehmen im Rahmen der allgemeinen realitätstheorie keine klassische Kraft Analyten mehr haben sollte wirklich eine Eigenschaft der Raumzeit als Rolfes.
Und dann kann man fragen wie wie bewegen sich halt.
Licht bewegt sich Licht Photonen in diese gekrümmten Raum zahlte und dann war da nicht Karl Schwarzschild der erste der da hat sozusagen das Konzept eines Schwarzen Lochs in der Welt Liedtext Juri.
Ausgerechnet hat Einstein hatte anfänglich seine Zweifel aber,
nach und nach denk ich mal war dann das Konzept der Schwarzen Löcher als solches akzeptiert wurden,
nur der Ex brennteile Beweis dafür für die Existenz ihrer schwarzen Löcher der liest dann bis in die 70er Jahre auf sich warten wo wir dann die ersten Hinweise von Renten Doppelstern hatten wo dann ein.
Begleiter zu einem sichtbaren Stern gab das eine Masse von,
mehr Sonnenmassen hat das mal wenn ich sehen konnte und dann hat man die ersten Hinweise dadurch dass ebensolche Begleiter schwarzes Loch sein könnte.
Und dann I denke ich mal akzeptiert du weißt es schwarze Löcher tatsächlich.
Axel existieren war dann denke ich mal die Beobachtungen der Bewegung der Sterne im Zentrum der Milchstraße der schreibt Genzel MPE und andere Kollegen,
die gezeigt haben dass bestimmte Sterne sich auf ihren Bahnen um ein unsichtbares Objekt bewegen,
das ungefähr vier Millionen Tonnen was nach dem Zentrum Milchstraße und die Tatsache dass man dieses Objekt nicht sehen konnte aber ganz klar compact genug ist und vier Millionen Sonnenmassen aber in sich konzentriert,
lies dann ein Prinzip keine andere Schlussfolgerungen zu dass ich im Zentrum Milchstraße um ein supermassives schwarzes Loch halten über das heute sagen.
Ja und dann.
Wann war diese Beobachtung.
Diesen in den 80er 90er Jahren die hat die Standard war am Anfang 90er Jahre total angefangen zu erfolgen und hatte dann die erste Nobitz die Daumen für 15 20 30 Jahre,
hat Melanie ihnen in den 2000er Jahren zum Essen geschlossen gesehen und dann hatte man heute eben die die idd macht die massenbestimmung.
Die Visualisierung mag die andere andere schon mal gesehen habe man hat halt total im Zentrum der Milchstraße relativ große Zahl von Sonnen die sich extrem hektisch umeinander drehen und teilweise daneben gerade in diesem Zentrums.
Enorm beschleunigt man das natürlich an sich schon mal ein sehr beschleunigt Visualisierung aber man merkt das relativ zu den Sternen die auch nur ein bisschen weiter weg sind die Beschleunigung extrem zunimmt das ist im Prinzip der Effekte in dieses Schwarze Loch,
ausüben nur dass man halt immer bisher auch was hat gesehen können wenn es eine entsprechende gravitative Wirkung gehabt.
Genauso man von man hat im Prinzip im ersten im großen in der keplerbahn von von Stern gesehen die sich in.
Im im Brennpunkt der eine Lipsy eine keplerbahnen Objekt hatten das Halten sprechen immer so haben muss Hund aus den verschiedenen Bahnen der beobachten stahlen kann man ziemlich schnell auf eine auf eine massenbestimmung ungefähr vier Millionen Sonnenmassen,
Fahrrad sich dann zwischendurch etwas nach oben unten korrigiert je nachdem wie auch die Entfernung vom Galaktischen Zentrum sich,
in der Messgenauigkeit verschoben hat aber das man wusste dass das Objekt ungefähr vier Millionen Sonnenmassen hat.
Und dann das ist eben dem Zentrum der einem in einen der Brennpunkte der der Bahn Ellipsen dieser Sterne stand.
Unterm dannheim Haltern verbessertem Beobachtungsmethoden diese Worbis viel genauer bestimmt und dadurch wurde auch die Idee die Messgenauigkeit dann machst du das schwarze und auch so besser und besser.
Ja da wir gerade ein Haken weil ich mein das ist ja dann ziemlich weit weg dieses Schwarze Loch von uns wie weit ist das.
8,58 8500k Verkehr sind ein paar viel sind 3 Lichtjahre und dann also ziemlich voll.
Okay und wie kann man das da beobachten dass man das also sehr viele Sterne in der Mitte.
Das Warze Loch Ness,
im optischen nicht zu sehen sie können müssen diese auch die Beobachtung der Stern in einem roten Objekt mal Licht machen so dass sie durch den Stau,
der zwischen uns und Ihnen und dem Lackieren Zentrum ist hindurchschauen können Imbiss also etwas längeren Frequenz gehen Radiowellen gehen problemlos durch optisches Licht wird geblockt durch den Stau,
und die Sterne kann man beobachten niemand hat etwas unter der optischen Wellenlängen geht hin zum infraroten hin und dann kann man dich dann verfolgen,
wir wissen als Radioastronomie schon seit längeren Zeit dass es dort im Zentrum der Milchstraße in der Tat eine Quelle gibt die wir sage Tarius erstanden.
Und in in den Laufe der der letzten 20 Jahre so hat sich mal wieder herausgestellt dass eben diese zentrale Objekt,
und dass ich dich gerne bewegen eben mit Sagittarius a stern.
Identisch ist unser Leben dass wir im Radiobereich zwar nicht das schwarze Loch selbst sehen,
aber das Radio liegt es heißen Plasmas dass sich unter schwarze Loch im Zentrum beweg.
Erinnerst Du Gartenaktion schreibe es wird schneller und schneller es fällt dann endlich in das schwarze Loch hinein bezüglich Schwerkraft sie geradezu uns in der GT frei wird hat sich das pass mal auf.
Und das strahlt dann im Radio Bereich entsprechend hell nur so gesehen erscheint Sagittarius a stern als helle Radio Quelle bzw,
eingebettet in den Händen Herr in das helle Plassmann im Radio Licht sichtbar ist und wir wissen dass es dasselbe Objekt ist um die es sich diese zentralen der im Sterne,
der sterne wie viel genannt werden Hals sich bewegen.
Oder Gatter schon ein Bild vom Schwarzen Loch.
Nein begab es hat noch nicht wir wissen halt nur das Nachladen Quelle ist und es war auch nicht das Bild ich warte noch so eines war halt eben nur die Strahlung des Plasmas das eben aus dem Bern Kernbereich kommt,
die Idee des eventuellen Teleskops ist es halt,
eben die Auflösung der Radio Messung und so weit nach oben zu treiben dass man in der Tat,
sozusagen die äußere Plasma Höhle die strahlt von dem zentralen dunklen Objekt halt unterscheiden kann und das ist das Bild was wir versuchen halt auch im galaktischen Zentrum zu sehen.
Jetzt würde ich ganz gerne mal ein bisschen genauer verstehen wie es eigentlich zu diesem schwarzen Loch kommt und was man sich an ich darunter vorstellen muss also jetzt haben wir schon in der verfallen lassen okay da kommt sehr viel Masse zusammen die Gravitation schwillt an.
Steht hätte ich aber die Frage warum passiert das überhaupt.
Am Prinzip kann sie schwarze Löcher von jeder will ich sagen beliebiger Maßnahme von verschiedenen Massen Bereichen.
Belara oder sogar von Mini schwarzen Löchern können Sie im Prinzip.
Habe Natur sie produziert vorfinden bis hin zu supermassive Schwarze Löcher und geht das nur darum wie eng haben sie diese Masse,
konzentriert um entsprechend der Raumkrümmung in der Umgebung so zu verändern dass ebenfalls,
informazione liegt hat nicht entkommen kann wie gesagt das z.b. einem hätte ein schwarzes Loch die Masse von von der Sonne würde es Objekte mit 3 km Radius sein,
das mag passieren es könnte sein dass Sterne von der Sonnengruß.
Von der hast du viel Calcium gegen hatten halt nicht passieren aber es tritt Prinzip spricht nichts dagegen dass man die Sonne auf konzentriert auf einem Radius kleiner ist 3 km da hätten wir auch ein schwarzes Loch,
du kannst die Masse im Prinzip immer Höhen und die der Rate schwarzendorf steigt in ja mit der Masse.
Das heißt also wenn Sie eine 1000000 Sonnenmassen haben dann sind 300 allein wie du sowas umgeht den drei Millionen Kilometer Radius.
Unten.
Wichtig ist halt wie dicht haben sie die Masse sozusagen konzentriert und sobald sie masz contortion klein ist halt irgendein Schwarzschildradius dizi 3 km pro Sondermasse dann erwachte x 2.
Jetzt ist er unsere Sonne nicht gerade die scheint ja noch so entscheiden heißt ja im Prinzip.
Sowohl ist es natürlich an sich ein sehr massives Ding also zu müssen Vergleich zur Erde das heißt die Gravitation hält das ja ganz ordentlich zusammen und drückt quasi nach innen.
Und das Fusion vorher das was die Sonne tatsächlich zum Strahlen bringt drückt wiederum mit dem Strahlungsdruck von innen nach außen und das hält den Sternen stabil.
Würde dieser Strahlungsdruck jetzt einfach wegfallen wäre dann.
Ist unumkehrbar das ist einfach zu einem schwarzen Loch wird was bringt einen Stern dazu in sich zusammen zu fallen.
Ja die Sonne wird halt nicht machen eben aus! Oder kommt mechanischen Gründen tatsächlich passiert ist folgendes wenn er tat sie haben mein strahlendes und thermischen Druck die der Gradation gehen wird in der Sonne,
wenn in der Tat der Diffusion Shrek direkt Reaktion aufgebraucht sind sozusagen im Falle der Sonne wird wahrscheinlich der Kohlenstoff der Fall sein dann wird die keine Energie mehr zurück in der Tat das Stern,
fällt in sich zusammen aber dann hat man einen anderen quantenmechanischen defekt ist und dem pauli Prinzip das eben verschiedene,
Imitat hallschmid halbschmidt halten Spinnen nicht im gleichen Quantenzustand einnehmen können und das wird da zu sein hatten Fermi Druck das heiße können diese Teilchen diese erzeugt haben nicht beliebig dich packen.
Einseitiger Fabi Druck wird dann sozusagen den Kollaps aufhalten im Fall der Sonne und im Wesentlichen Weißen Zwerg hat Zeugen der Weiße Zwerg irgendwie größer der Erde haben.
Mit dem Bruchteil der Sonnenmasse dass das übrig geblieben ist wo es keine dies ist wenn äußere Hüllen wahrscheinlichen aus planetarischer Nebel in ins inference Weltraum.
Erinnerung abgestoßen aber der innere Kern wird ein Weißer Zwerg sein wo im Wesentlichen das farmy.ch der Fermi Druck ausgelöst durch das Pauli-Prinzip,
den Weißen Zwerg am weiteren Kollaps eben stoppt und eben.
Weiter fürs Rest des Universums euch einig wo sich hinweg.
Das heißt er ist sozial einen quantenmechanischen gründen,
ein Grund Druck da der sozialen diese vollständige zusammenfallen verhindert weil die Sonne insgesamt nicht genug
sie ist aber nicht groß genug um wirklich komplett in sich zusammenfallen zu können weil er am Schluss noch ein Rest Druck ist der noch mal zusätzlich überwunden werden muss,
aber dafür ist nicht genug Masse da.
Genau dann geht's aber noch ein zweites Sicherheitsventil sozusagen das wenn der Stern sage ich mal 20 mal die Masse der Sonne hat.
Dann wird kein wasserzwerge zurück sondern ein Neutronenstern dann ist der Caller reichte kollapsar sozusagen und über den Weißen Zwerg hinaus Elektronen Protonen zu Neutronen zusammen zu schmelzen in Werther Wetter Zufall.
Sie bekommt ein Objekt das vornehmlich aus Patronen besteht Neutronen sind auch Fermionen das gilt das pauli Prinzip.
Nur das hier das Objekt das entsteht hat nicht die Größe der Erde hat,
sondern vielmehr 20 km Durchmesser ungefähr in einer Thron Stern und daher der Vermietung der Neutronen beim Weißen Zwerg Wasser fermidruck der Elektronen hier sitzt der Vermietung der Neutronen,
diesen Kollaps auf das heißt auch da wird dann der Natron Stern für die Rest des Universums sozusagen existieren,
nur bei stern die dann wiederum mehr Masse haben als eben 20 30 40 Sonnenmassen dann Reich selbst dieser Vermietung der Neutronen nicht aus und Kollaps aufzuhalten und dann kollabiert es durchtrennt schwach.
Was heißt denn was hat Zwergstern weißt nein.
Da weißt du dass wir besser weiß genannt weil er hauptsächlich im uwm ultravioletten oder am weichen runden Licht scheint,
und vom farblichen her würde das 2-Sitzer erscheinen deshalb man sieht ein Audio USB z.b. ist ein Weißer Zwerg,
also das macht schon Sinn der Name Neutronensterne werden auch eine Millionen Grad heiß sein,
auch da kann man sagen sie ist auch gleiche Hemd weiß aber weiß nicht wann es wirklich so die hat man mit optischen Auge mit abdichtungs Gruppen gesehen.
Wie lottery Sirius MB ist ein Weißer Zwerg der Macht der Name Sinn,
da drunter sind sehr viel kleiner dabei eigentlich nie gedacht hast die postuliert worden sind in 30er Jahren dass man die Himmel zu sehen.
Und da kam halt auch geradeaus tun mir zu helfen jemanden halten und hohenstein z.b. Radio Pulsar beobachten kann heute mit mit Hubble und runden Teleskopen kann man denn der Tat.
Thermische Strahlung von Oberfläche von Siena Neutronensterne gerade Nordsee.
Aber in der ganze Zeit sind sie am besten im Radio Licht zu Opa.
Okay das heißt wir können jetzt mal so grob drei sternarten nach Größe unterscheiden
dass unser Langweiler Sonnensystem sososo durchschnitten Durchschnitts Planetensystem ohne besondere Erwähnung scraped mit einer Sonne die dann später einfach so eine weiße Kugel,
kriegt man einfach so rum oder was also ist ein so da und das war's.
Wie wird da sein die wird sich langsam abkühlen es gibt so eine Kühlung Kühlung skoven von weißen Zwergen,
halt wenn man weißen Zwerg findet kann man von der rechtlichen Leucht kaufen fürs Alter abschätzen ja so wissen ziemlich genau wie weiße Zweige sich abkühlen,
das mag von der Zusammensetzung noch etwas abhängen manche haben wir Kohlenstoff manchmal haben wir Helium,
was eben dieses Restprodukt der Fusionen im so einen ähnlichen sterben war aber das war es in dem Wissen hin C Kohlenstoff Sauerstoff und und Helium und die die Mission bestimmt dann ja sozusagen wieder was trage ich ab.
Und in der Tat ist die werden dann vor sich hin kühlen und wenn sie jetzt nicht zufälligerweise begleite ich danach haben der zwischendurch noch mal Masse,
auf diesen weißen Zwerg Abladen Canvas vorkommt dann hat man Rücken drunten Doppelsternsysteme,
dann wird auch immer Weißer Zwerg sein aber es gibt sogenannte Supernova eins Explosionen wo dann begleite ich dann immer wieder in,
in Abständen Masse auf den Weißen Zwerg ablädt und es dann zur thermonuklearen Explosion und Oberfläche gibt die dann theoretisch auch zur das Zerstören des Weißen Zwerges oder aber auch durch den Kollaps Neutronensternen zu viel Masse,
abgelagert wird führen kann aber das hängt dann wieder davon ab was für ein Begleiter da ist.
Ramen Sonnensystem nicht.
Im Sonnensystem Sonne ist eine witzigerweise ein ein isolierter Sterne wohl die Mehrzahl der Sterne in der Milchstraße tatsächlich Doppelsternsystem ist.
Das weiß man mittlerweile Doppelsterne also noch langweiliger als.
Wir sind noch langweiliger als also die Adresse genommen.
Okay also.
Normale sonnengröße langweilig habe festgestellt so etwas größer 10 bis 20 Mal so groß,
wird wahrscheinlich dann ein Neutronenstern und der macht zumindest die Radioastronomie froh weil da wird einfach viel gestrahlt,
komme zu den ganz dicken Dingern am,
gibt's ja auch mehr als genug von also riesige Sonnen sind überall die,
komm dann auch irgendwann an ihr Lebensende also genau dieser Punkt wo sozusagen der Strahlungsdruck nicht mehr ausgereicht um die Gravitation der Gesamtmasse zusammenzufassen.
Was passiert dann also was läuft dann.
Wie bei der,
formations Neutronenstern kommt es zunächst zu einer Supernova Explosion es war sechs Personen in der Tat sozusagen die inneren Teile der Stern zusammen fahren weil die gerade zwanzig mehr aufgehört.
Und zumindest mal Neutronenstern passiert sein so vor sich dass die Höhlen sozusagen auf diesem Fest Metro und dann sich gerade im Inneren die bildhaft aufprallen,
und ich höre Schicht nach außen geschleudert werden und dann entsprechend eben nächstes uns artiges.
Agnes Erfolg das auch so hell ist wie eine gesamte Galaxie also auf dem weiten zu beobachten dass das sind sogar supernova2,
Explosion oder core collapse Supernova wie man sie heutzutage nennen.
Und wenn die Masse aber wenn immer mehr mehr machst aber das dann halt noch größer ist als der Vorgänger Sterne als hat hohenstern Zimmer mehr machst du nach innen fällt dann wie gesagt kollabiert der innere Kern zu einem schwarzen Loch,
durch uns gibt's trotzdem eine Explosion aber halt im Hintern an wahrscheinlich ein Spaß.
Und wenn man ganz massiven Stamm hantiert dann kann man auch z.b. hypernova wir müssen and kreieren,
die dann vermutlich einen Teil der Sonden gamma-ray bursts erklärt die wurden auch.
Schwarzes Loch im Internet zurück wird aber auch in Chat und dieser sichert wird dann immer Gamma Bereich als heller Blitz bei der Explosion festgestellt mit unseren Teleskopen,
und hat sogar der Kamerablitz regis.
Also es kommt quasi eine Supernova zusammen mit mit diesem eigentlichen Kollaps.
Im Inneren was heißt da fliegt dann viel weg und muss es ganz man Zeitraffer anschaut macht bunte Bilder und super wallpaper.
Am aber in der Mitte befindet sich der Großteil dieser Masse zusammen und dann kommt es zu diesem Überschreiten einer Schwelle.
Wie.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen also was geht denn da im Inneren ab wenn so viel Masse zusammen kommt und wie trennt sich das vom vom Rest ab.
Ideam was wirklich mehr dann abläuft das können wir halt schwer beschreiben weil.
Informationen nackt, jetzt zu den Eigenschaften von Schwarzen Löchern.
Jenseits des runden Ereignishorizont wie der Name schon sagt halt uns nicht mehr erreichen das wird vermutlich im Innern eine Singularität geben das heißt wo so viel Masse auf einen.
Minimalradius konzentriert ist da bricht unsere Physik Wiese existiert zusammen und.
Wir können aber diese Vorgänge nicht wirklich man kann sie zwar versuchen zu berechnen aber wir werden nie.
Diese Vorgänge tatsächlich verifizieren können weil wir heben.
Aus diesem Bereich den wir eigens Horizont nennen der und so zu einer sinere vom schwarzen laufen im äußeren Universum Trend mir Informationen erfahr empfangen können,
also die die Tatsache dass lichtdichte kommen kann würdet auch das Information hat solltest nicht entkommen kann.
Unter der gibt zwar Diskussion Wien weiters mit der krank Mechanik vereinbar ist los von den Verbrechen und so weiter,
aber im Wesentlichen haben wir ein Objekt,
das vom Rest des Universums vollkommen abgeschirmt ist und das ist halt eben dann der schwarze Loch die wie gesagt,
selbst wenn sie mit den stärksten Raketen oder was immer versuchen würden sich dem.
Abwärtstrend sozusagen Anführungsstrichen sending gegen zu setzen sie würden dem Schwarzen Loch hinkommen können wenn sie einmal den Ereignishorizont überschritten haben.
Mit dieser Krümmung habe ich eine Frage also.
Die Singularität in der Mitte was heißt das also das ist dann alles so groß wie eine Murmel oder,
das dann übertrieben als ich meine schwarze Loch hat ja an sich eine Ausdehnung bis zu diesem Punkt wo ab wo man sozusagen nicht mehr entkommen kann,
oder wenn man sich dem Schwarzen Loch,
Nehat gibt es diesen Punkt wo eben die Gravitation des Schwarzen Loch so starkes das halt keinen Weg mehr zurück gibt das ist der von ihm beschriebene,
Event Ereignishorizont was kommt dann dann kommt erstmal nichts.
Nein das Problem wird sein dass sie Raum und Zeit nicht trennen kann es ist in der realitätstheorie ist das ein.
Keine Gemeinsamkeit und Sie können Raum und Zeit nicht voneinander trennen was er da auch passiert ist dass wenn sie sich im Schwarzen Loch nähern dass ihre Uhr immer langsamer.
So langsam das im Prinzip gar nicht für Sie den Ereignishorizont praktisch nie überschreiten sie nähern sich ernähren sich nähern sich aber es dauert länger länger und länger und länger.
Unter Imperativ von auswärtigen Bürobedarf.
Sehen Sie dann die wenn ich jetzt mal zu laut betrachten würde der Reinfeld der wurde praktisch für immer da verharren würde sich was nicht.
Bewegendes einfach weil eben das Licht länger und länger braucht bis es bei uns ankommt und für Sie als Astronaut der Reinfeld wird ihre Uhr als solches immer langsamer werden.
Dann hat sie wäre erstmal gar nicht merken ob sie den heever Eventreisen muss in eine Hauswand wirklich beschritten haben.
Wenn ich wenn ich so ein bisschen außen stehe und jemand beim reinfallen zu schaue dann sehe ich am Schluss quasi nur noch so ein Foto von dieser Person weil quasi das letzte Licht was rausgeht bleibt mehr oder wie.
Unterm und selbst wenn sie wenn sie es registrieren würden Wiese reinfahren gibt.
Es fällt immer das Stichwort der spaghettifizierung wo dann halt der gerade jetzt sozusagen der Krümmung,
ihren Füßen ganz andere ist das bei ihren also im Kopf das heißt sie werden die Länge gezogen das ganze wird aber noch etwas komplizierter wenn der schwarze lauf sich wahrscheinlich dreht wie es in der Realität wahrscheinlich überall vorkommen wird.
Und man kann versuchen halt auszurichten was mir noch ein schwarzes Loch passiert aber da das Problem wird sein dass du es wirklich nie Werdenfels.
Na gut wenn wir noch mal bei der Theorie wenn er sich jetzt diese diese unheimliche Masse dieser Singularität jetzt Raum und Zeit so extrem.
Grund warum Verbleib,
also warum hat denn das Ding dann an sich überhaupt noch einen Gravitationseffekt krümmt es nicht die Raumzeit so extrem dass selbst die Gravitation dann nicht mehr herauskommen kann.
Minions Mann der sie kann jetzt gerade dazu nicht von der Raumzeit entkoppeln SSO sein dasselbe selber.de Danny die rock addition ist die Krümmung der Raumzeit was heißt der Raum bleibt ja weiter gekrümmt ist ja nicht so als dies würde die Krümmung verschwinden,
sie können halt nur im Jenseits eines eine Distanz von der Singularität her keine Informationen mehr empfangen aber wenn die z.b. die Sonne durch ein schwarzes Loch setzen womit genau eine Sonnenmasse.
Hätte das für uns auf der Erde überhaupt keine Konsequenz abgesehen davon ist wirklich kein Sonnenlicht mehr bekommen,
aber was die Bewegung der Erde in der Planeten allgemein damit zu tun als wäre es kein Unterschied das Objekt,
erzeugt dann war da das dieselbe Masse hat dieselbe Raumkrümmung wie halt Sonne nur also vom weiten gesehen auf dem,
motivtasse der Konzentriertheit des Objekts inzwischen eine andere aber sie könnte man sie wie in der Tat,
die Sonne durch die in beliebiges einmassen Objekte ersetzen und es sich würde für uns erstmal großartig nichts zu ändern.
Bitte den starke Gravitation im Schwarzen Loch ist es ja eigentlich relativ wahrscheinlich dass immer mehr Materie hinein fällt.
Was wird ja alles angezogen irgendwann kommt es dem so nah überschreitet Ereignishorizont und das Ding wird quasi immer dicker und immer dicker und immer schwerer und hat an ihm noch mehr Gravitationswirkung was das ja dann wiederum noch weiter beschleunigen kann.
Wenn er jetzt so viel Masse reinfällt.
Was hält alles das schwarze Loch davon ab wieder so einen Prozess zu beginnen und wieder ein neues Feuer zu entfachen.
Weil die Bedingungen für Kernfusion haben andere.
Umwelteinflüsse sozusagen die als dieser im schwarzes loch existieren müssen halt versuchen z.b.
Die kannst du dann so langsamer Prozess tatsächlich,
aber wir müssen trotzdem versuchen Proton nah zusammenbekommen um Hals otrium zu erzeugen und so weiter dieser dieser Vorgang wären am schwarzen doch aufgrund der großen Dichte,
jetzt mal so gar nicht kann ich mach.
Also ich glaube nicht dass wir da warten sollten das da neuer Stern entsteht aber ein schwarzes Loch nimmt in der Tat mit der Masse zu vergrössern,
so auf das schwarze Loch im Zentrum Milchstraße aber die die Zuwachsrate ist jetzt nicht wo du bei mir und es großartig ja Sorgen machen müsst.
Gut aber wenn in diesem schwarzen Loch quasi die wird also,
wenn ich das gerade richtig dass die Physik wie wir sie bisher definierende nicht alle nicht unbedingt alle Antworten hat für das was in dieser Singularität stattfindet dann wäre es ja theoretisch auch vorstellbar dass dort noch irgendetwas.
Entsteht was wir so noch gar nicht.
Es hat nur amag.at postulieren wenn man es halt nicht überprüfen kann und das.
Ladies man Didi Didi es gibt immer Widerspruch zwischen der mal wieder Sport geht immer noch Diskussionsbedarf zwischen der Quantenmechanik und der DDR.
Café Sohns Physik in dem Sinne was wird wirklich am Ereignishorizont passiert gutes Beispiel ist wie gesagt.
Die sollen drucken Strahlung wo halt man sagt was glauben ich Warzen doch kommt halt nichts raus es scheint aber doch so zu sein dass wenn man z.b.
Virtuelle Teilchen hatte immer wieder eine im Rahmen Quantenmechanik existieren und löschen,
dass man sozusagen Teilchen Antiteilchen konstant erzeugt und wir verschmelzen das wenn das Name Arktis holzuhren ist das dann auf einmal eines dieser beiden Paare verschwindet,
das andere bleibt dann übrig und damit strahlt dann doch nicht was das Loch.
Ist damit aber Informationsfluss verloren gegangen oder nicht und es gibt da unter den Experten halt.
Teilweise hitzige Diskussionen ob dann halt ein schwarzes Loch wirklich ein volles mit Nation bedeutet und nicht rum.
Aber Tatsache ist dass die dass die Details der Physik von Schwarzen Löchern gerade im Grenzbereich mit der Quantenmechanik von sich.
Docking Strahlung ist ja nach sieben Hawking benannt vor wenigen Jahren verstorbener Wissenschaftler auch einer,
dr populärsten aufgrund seiner Erscheinung aber auch nur sich aufgrund seiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit schwarze Löcher war ja so ein bisschen seinen sein Lieblingsthema.
Und diese Hawking-Strahlung ist.
Eine noch nicht überprüfte oder noch nicht bewiesene Theorie richtig das heißt und und bedeutet es dass nur etwas.
Strahlt oder bedeutet etwas bedeutest das etwas heraus strahlt aus dem Schwarzen Loch weil das würde ja nicht der Idee des Schwarzen Lochs widersprechen so ein bisschen.
Ja wie gesagt das ist die das ist genau DEAD die Frage immer mit dem sich beschäftigt.
Häfen auswärtige Beobachter der ist in der Tat aus als wäre es eine Strahlung die aus dem Schwarzen Loch kommt weil man eben das andere Antiteilchen das halt erzeugt wurden ist eben nicht sieht und man sieht halt nur das was soziales hat.
Anton dazu das dann rauskommt.
Aber ja das ist ja und ist immer der der der der der der der Kontrast. Zwischenhalt kommt Mechanik und und wird die tätest du ja solltest das ist genau wo leben die,
und Ahnenforschung sich darauf konzentriert zu unter anderen um halt festzustellen wie sind die beiden Theorien tatsächlich kompatibel miteinander ist eine der wenigen,
Bereiche wo dann wirklich Quantenphysik auf Relativitätstheorie trifft und klar das endgültige Ziel das ist formulieren also eine Quantentheorie der hoffentlich.
Alle diese Aspekte mit löst aber selbst dort roten Steine sind im Biene Prinzip schon,
angewandte Quantenmechanik im Bereich der Gravitation weil eben herzferne Prinzip works und die hat hohen Sterne handgravieren verhindert,
diese dann für kollektionstext benutzen kann und das macht denke ich mal sie haben unter gesagt das Mysterium ich war schon durch also ein bisschen aus weil es immer noch im Bereich ist.
Den wir mit unserer versickert noch nicht schließen können wo wir halt genau an an den Grenzen angekommen sind die wir halt verstehen ich meine,
das Konzept der schwarzen Wäsche Wiegand hat selbst lange gebraucht Max ST akzeptiert zu werden und erst heute die beobachten.
Unten Doppelsternen die sich was du noch nicht hast oder gerade leygo mit der Entdeckung der schwarzen Löchern vom,
30 bis 70 Sonnenmassen hat dann gezeigt dass das schwarze Löcher hat sich existieren.
Viele schwarze Löcher sind entdeckt worden indem in den Mittelpunkt einer Galaxie.
Und alle schwarzen Löcher im Mittelpunkt einer Galaxie und haben,
alle Mittelpunkte einer Galaxie ein schwarzes Loch also ist das sozusagen etwas was jetzt spezifisch nur dort existiert oder gibt überall schwarze Löcher wahrscheinlich und man hat sie bloß noch nicht gesehen weil sie so.
Billiger.de schwarze Löcher die man in Röntgen Doppelsternsystem postuliert hat zum die Beobachtung zu erklären die haben typischerweise 13 Sonnenmassen oder so.
Die ich war von Löchern die Midlayer diktiert worden sind als erstes event AWO daneben zwei zu schwarzen Löchern. 35 bis 40 Sonnenmassen verschmolzen sind zu 68 Sonnenmassen Schwarzen Loch.
Die schwarzen Löchern fand man nicht überraschen dass sie extra das als als ich hotslog existieren sondern vielmehr war dies Sternentwicklung.
Erstmal überrascht dass diese überhaupt eine Stange wickeln her zurück werden können das war das Feuer erstaunlich aber leider nicht so sehr dass ich wach bin durch damit nach,
Masse von 70 Sonnenmassen existieren und vielmehr wie kommt ein Stern denn dazu Sohn 35 Watt Solar für Sonnenmassen schwarzes Loch zu erzeugen,
da gibt's mittlerweile Wege das in der Tat nachdem,
nachdem finden immer etwas schlauer per diese zu erklären aber und dann denkt man dann so einen die nächstgrößere Größe sind schwarze Löcher so ganze intermediate Mrs black holes,
die man z.b. Kugelsternhaufen im Zentrum vermutete wenn inhaltsmasse in der Tat zusammen,
sich konzentriert weil es in Gottes Hand bringen zahlst ist Kugelsternhaufen zusammenfällt könnte sich in der Tat aus der zusammenbildung verschiedener massereicher Sterne im Kuhstall Haufen Sonderzug,
Termin Meth black hole erzeugen da gab es verschiedene.
Behauptungen dass man solche schwarzen Löchern Ansprüche von 10.000 Sonnenmassen oder so entdeckt hat,
aber ich würde sagen keines dieser keine dieser Behauptungen denke ich mal hatte bis jetzt wirklich alle Test unangefochten bestanden.
Und dann ist der Vorstellung dass es supermassive Schwarze Löcher im Zentrum der Milchstraße oder.
Die ist schon älter die kommt auch aus der Deckung der Khasaren 60er Jahre her und hatte alte Objekte gefunden die.
Oma nicht sehr am Anfang nicht wusste sind sie sehr nah oder sehr weit weg und wenn sie sehr weit weg sind hätte das auf einmal bedeutet das E auf der leuchtstark.
Arm sein müssten und durch verschiedene Beobachtung hat man dann schließlich in der Tat wäre beziehen können dass sie sehr weit weg sind.
Was heißt brauchen auf einmal eine Objekt mir das sehr viel Leuchtkraft erzeugt.
Und die effektivste Art und Weise Leuchtkraft erzeugen ist in der Tat Materien schwarzes Loch Einfalls lassen.
Auf diese Art und Weise hat man dann recht schnell eben dann die Theorie entwickelt,
dass sich diese Quasare darstellen lassen als eben supermassive Schwarze Löcher im Zentrum von Galaxien,
die dann halt massakrieren und diese Masse dann in Strahlung umwandeln die wir dann hier bei der Erde als Kader Strahlung sozusagen sehen,
hinzu kommt dass man mit hochauflösenden Aufnahmen soll im Radiobereich wollten wir die Einmessungen halt aussuchen Fidget sehen konnten also strahlend für strahlenförmige.
Ausstöße die sich aus dem Zentrum dieser Galaxien hat diesen Zentrum dieser Galaxien entstehen.
Und das ist in dem Wesentlichen Materie Ausbrüche die sich in den sozusagen senkrecht zu der Sekretion Scheiben und die ist das Gas in der schwarzen,
anordnen und die durch das Magnetfeld der schwarzen Loch sozusagen fokussiert werden und.
Weil wir hart Ebensee Quasare kennen Gewissen diese dass diese Galaxien,
Radio Galaxy in diese T-Shirts haben aktive galaktische Kerne haben und du hat man mittlerweile das einheitliche Bild das in der Tat.
Wir in jeder großen Galaxy IV2 und zumindest von der Sonne willstraße z.b.
Ein supermassives schwarzes Loch im Zentrum erwarten wo es halt Aktion Scheiben geht wo Gas in Energie umgewandelt wird dass wir dann als intensive Radiostrahlung blonde aber auch anwenden Bereichen ziehen können,
und wenn wir eine günstige Ausrichtung haben von der Geometrie her dann können wir am teilweise auch die sind jetzt sehen der aus der sozusagen aussehen.
Polak deutsches Haus der schwarzen durch ist der schwarzen durch Einstich.
Aber davon ausgehen dass sind in jeder Galaxie in der Mitte ein schwarzes Loch ist und supermassives schwarzes Loch ist dann.
Was was ist füreinander der Grund also bildet quasi die Galaxie,
zwangsläufig diese schwarzen Löcher aus oder entsteht quasi die Galaxie um so ein supermassives Loch und das ist dann überhaupt erst der der Antrieb für für diese eigentliche Galaxien Bildung.
Da liegen sie wie eine Finger genau auf einen zentralen Punkt der aktuellen Forschung was ist das Huhn was das Ei was bedingt das eine was anderes gibt vermutlich eine symbiotische Beziehung zwischen den beiden aber es ist in der Tat,
wir sehen mittlerweile gibt es ganz klare Messungen dass es,
Korrelation Beziehungen gibt zwischen den Eigenschaften der Galaxien zumindest im Zentralbereich und den Eigenschaften der Schwarzen Löcher wie z.b. Masse und so weiter,
die man halt von allen Beobachtungen her,
nehmen kann auf diese Art und weisse weiß man hatte das in der Tat schwarze.
Notar teilweise für für die Vorgänge im Zentrum dieser Galaxien verantwortlich ist aber umgekehrt auch natürlich das schwarze Loch,
Haie von der von abhängig von der Ente ihren Eigenschaften wie die zentralen Bedingungen die semmelstraße aussehen als eine des sich von dem andere scheint nicht trennen aber was das eine jetzt was der Grund und was die Ursache ist muss die andere die Wirkung ist,
darüber wird halt momentan auch in der Tat diskutiert wir wissen z.b. auch oder vermuten.
Dass die großen Galaxien die will wissen wie wir sie sehen,
durch das Verschmelzen kleinere Galaxien ich Kollision von zwei Hunden Katze kleineren Galaxien entstanden sind das heißt wir haben dieses hieratische Bild der galaxienentstehung verkleiner Galaxien,
ich mich melden sich zu größeren und die wieder verschmelzen sich noch geholfen und so weiter.
Also hast ihren Ende halt so große Galaxien haben wie Andromeda Milchstraße und selbst Andromeda Milchstraße momentaner Kollisionskurs,
runter ein paar Milliarden Jahre werden die auch die beiden Galaxien zusammenstoßen und das über was ihre schwarze Loch in der Milchstraße wird mit Obamas in schwarz noch Andromeda-Galaxie erstmal im Binärsystem bilden,
wenn das passiert dann gibt's gerade zu uns wellen dann sieht man doch dazu uns wehren,
in sehr viel Langenweddingen Bereich azimetli go leygo messbar sind mit Lisa wird mir sie messen können oder aber auch impulsan z.b. denn immer wenn,
die ganzen Songs werden wenn die schwarzen Löchern Sonnentanz bilden dann breit nicht gerade zu uns wenn Haus und lieblich Einfluss and die,
Ankunftszeit und Apotheke hier in der willstraße und wenn man diese Variationen messen können dann dann habe ich auch gar zu uns werden von solchen,
bin ja ein Schwachsinn Deutschland deckt oder etwa zu BBM 780 Doppelsternsystem oder Doppel schwarzes Loch hin soll ich sagen.
Dann sind das genau die Voraussetzungen wie wir sie hier auf der Erde für unsere,
Agaplesion Sven extra mit Butan erwarten würde und so etwas besseres schöneres an einen modernen astrophysicists ist irgendwie alles.
Verbunden miteinander eine Auswirkungen Erkenntnis in einem Bereich hat direkt eine Erkenntnisse EM gewinnen auf vielleicht anderen Gebieten und,
Astrophysik kann man heutzutage halt nicht mehr in den kleinen Nischen machen sondern muss wirklich verstehen,
wie die Bereich Männer zusammenhängen und mit leygo hat man jetzt wunderbares neues Fenster,
thuniversum eröffnet in der Mehrzweckhalle Todesfällen nach Objekten schauen kann also wir haben Prinzip Gattungsware Gastronomie gerade begründet.
Und mit dem Bilder von Schwarzen Löchern wie wir jetzt halts mit dem enthalten Teleskop Coloration machen können aber jetzt sind zusätzliches neues Bild von Schwarzen Löchern.
Maassen in des Wortes aufnehmen können und diese Kombination der Informationen aus den verschiedensten,
Breichen mit dem Friedens Methoden ist halt was gerade momentan die die Frau auch schon so spannend.
Okay also ich will noch mal kurz darauf eingehen also,
diese Aussicht das Andromeda und die Milchstraße miteinander verschmelzen ist vielleicht der bessere Begriff weil Kollision,
würde ja sozusagen so bisschen dieses Bild oh Gott da kommen Tausende von Sonnen und die stoßen dann alle zusammen aber ich bis es richtig sehe ist es gerade aktiv unwahrscheinlich dass er überhaupt irgendwas zusammen stößt weil einfach die Abstände,
Pedro sind trotz alledem habe ich das gerade so verstanden dass die schwarzen Löcher schon zwangsläufig irgendwann zueinander finden würden.
Genau also wir gehen davon aus dass in der Tat ist wenigstens etwas löschen gibt es gibt immernoch hast du physikalische Probleme so unter Last perfekt Problem wie wir denn,
die den Text einmal gesondert den den den Drehmoment loswerden dann bin ich eigentlich verschmelzen,
wir müssen also als Betrieb irgendwo Reibung haben um den Drehimpuls zu verlieren damit die beiden Dinger wirklich verschmelzen.
Wir gehen aber von aus dass es in der Tat passiert wenn wir sehen auch so gibt wunderbare Hubble Aufnahmen wo dann tatsächlich wir Galaxien gerade am verschmelzen sind,
unter auch teilweise ist es dann auch erklärbar wie wir so wie wir zu diesem großen Massen von Schwarzen Löchern kommen die mal eben halt eher kleinere schwarz-weiß verschmolzen haben.
Das hat wenn zwei Galaxien verschmelzen sind die schwarzen Löcher in der Mitte an ist das einzige was an Hasi aufeinandertreffen.
Als anderes relativ lebe ich schon gesagt haben und Klaas mag dort Okklusion kommen aber im Wesentlichen ist jetzt.
Bei Flüssen die sich auch so sehr dass wir dann einfach ihre Bahnen ändern.
Schwarze Löcher die Sterne.
Die Sterne meine ich jetzt.
Ja die wunderbare noch mehr Simulationen wo sie z.b. sehen wie Andromeda Milchstraße noch schöner werden halt ein paar Sterne ins Weltall raus geschleudert und dem Sohn und Slingshot haben also da passiert alles,
aber natürlich auch Zeit Garantie für uns jetzt nicht so relevant sind da sagt keiner.
Die Sonne dann auch schon ein Weißer Zwerg.
Kann ich so nicht weiter 2 oder Burger schlimmstenfalls davor ist jetzt im Roten Riesen geworden und habe die Erdbahn aufgefressen also das sind Probleme mit dem wir uns erstmal nicht beschäftigen müssen.
Okay jetzt,
gibt's dieses schöne Experiment das Event Reisenthel.
Event Horizon den Ereignishorizont bezieht sich natürlich ganz klar auf schwarze Löcher und das Ziel war
nun denn endlich mal ein wirkliches Bild zu bekommen und eben nicht nur nachweisen zu können ok alles klar da gibt's halt Strahlung können wir Infrarot, irgendwie mit Radio Teleskopen irgendwie nachmessen dass da was ist aber wie es genau angeordnet ist,
wissen wir nicht.
Wie kam es zu diesem Projekt man musste ja in der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft muss ja sozusagen auch überhaupt erstmal dieser dieser Wunsch herausbilden weil vorstellen kann man sich eine Menge,
bis dann irgendwann mal konkret zu durch einen Kollaborationen kommt was was ist da abgegangen wann hat das angefangen wer hat da miteinander geredet.
Die ersten grundsätzlich nie den Papiere dazu gab es Anfang 70er Jahre zwar nicht mit schwarzen Ross in schwarzen Löchern soll mit mit Sternen und stellaren Schwarzen Löchern was muss man sehen altanea entfernen.
Unterm ich denke das erste Bescheid jetzt Beschreibung des axumin das Olchis wie wir das durchgeführt haben ist.
Von der polykation von Heine Falke und Kollegen gewesen 2000 das in der war damals.
Doch gerade mit seiner Doktorarbeit fertig hier im MMP verrate auszunehmen ich habe mit ihm teilweise noch über Nacht als Doktorand.
Und es war ganz klar schon damals dass man hat sich überlegt hat damals war im wesentlichen das schwarze Loch Zentrum Milchstraße erstmal relevant weil es das zwar nicht das Größte aber ist nächste,
und somit zumindest Bussmann ungefähr die ich die größte schwarze Loch die man abbilden muss sozusagen,
was heißt er sie wissen wie weit es weg ist sie wissen aufgrund der Masse wie groß ist also können sich ausrechnen welche Auflösung sie brauch.
Und was hast du nun weiß man die Auflösung eines Teleskops ist gegeben durch die Wellenlänge und die Größe der Patura ihres Teleskops.
Und dann stellen Sie sich leider schnell fest dass sie ich ein Teleskop von der Größe der Erde brauchen.
Runde wernings dadurch bedingt dass die Strahlung erheben.
Auf dem Gardasee in der Scheibe sitzen von der Milchstraße und die Strahlung eben,
durch die Scheibe durch musst lustige streu das Warzen auf Worte müssen verschmiert größer als das kann sich vorstellen so über den,
neblige Straße gehen die schwarze Straßenlampen an dann sind die Straßen haben Straßenlampen sonnenhalo der einfach dass das gestreute wird,
Lichter Straßenlampe von der.
Öffne Wassertropfen im Handy und im Nebel ist und so wird auch das Bild der des Bilder Milchstrahl der schwarzen offene Mensch adunistraße gestreut und den interstellaren Medium,
diese Streuung nimmt aber ab indem es zu hören hören Volk einzugehen und damit landen sie im Prinzip bei den herausfordern müssen.
Millimeterwellen gehen in deinem Fall sind 1,3 mm Werning sind 230 Gigahertz und zu einem Ops Teleskop das hat die Größe der Erde.
Und dann frage ich dann erstmal aber die Technologie dafür und es war tatsächlich 2000 und nicht der Fall aber gerade hier im Institut haben.
Ich mein Teleskop der Größe Erde war eh klar dass man das nicht bauen.
Ja aber man hat das Prinzip der WLAN baseline TV mit re das ist eine Technik die unter anderen halt in England entwickelt worden ist Martin Reihl hat dafür Note 470 ml Preis bekommen.
Wo man im Prinzip die Daten der Teleskope separat aufnehmen kann im Radio Bereich,
da wir es aber mit Radiobereich sozusagen erlauben uns erlauben können dass in elektrischen Spannung umzuwandeln was nun,
können wir sozusagen alle Informationen aufnehmen und die nachher sozusagen miteinander verbinden und können dadurch ein Bild rekonstruieren.
Umso mehr Teleskope man hat umso besser die Bildqualität im Prinzip,
kann sich das so vorstellen sie haben nehmen Sie inständig Folge hätten schwarze Pappe die sie über ihre Teleskope Größe der Erde liegen und überall da wo sie jetzt den Grad Hiltrup zu verstehen haben haben sie dann noch in ihrer,
Pappe durch das überstehen können wenn Sie die Pappe mit der Erddrehung drehen dann können sozusagen die Apertur des Teleskops ausfüllen,
und idealerweise mit sehr viel Teleskopen oder es ist meistens nicht mehr möglich wir haben meistens nur ne Handvoll MRT hatten wir heute 8 Uhr.
Und dann muss natürlich Algorithmen haben die sozusagen aus der Informationen die wir von diesen 8 Teleskopen oder wir heute wissen am Ende sind,
und de tritt Rotation dann sozusagen auf das reale Bild zurückschließen.
8 Teleskope waren dabei.
Gib mir aber weil man eben bei diesen 230g hat diese Beobachtung machen musste nicht jedes Teleskop ist dazu in der Lage und nicht jedes diskopathie.
Enddarm Sauce haben im Prinzip alle Teleskope teilgenommen im April 2017 die dazu in der Lage waren mittlerweile bauen wir weitere Teleskope dazu.
Kollegen aus Asien und Amerika haben in grün und jetzt ein Teleskop aufgebaut das wird bei der nächsten Beobachtung dabei sein,
und unsere französischen Kollegen haben auch plateau de Bürgers Nähe von Grenoble ein Teleskop oder tatsächlich zehn Teleskope sind das die zusammengefasst werden,
so ausgerüstet auf diese diese Cisco verbunden beim nächsten mal mitmachen kann also die die anzahl Teleskope wird sich vergrößern bei den zukünftigen Beobachtung.
Du musst es also die Teleskope die dabei sind also muss man sich diese Anforderung also erstens natürlich wollen dann müssen Sie die richtigen Frequenzbereich haben aber Sie müssen auch nicht richtige Richtung gucken.
Das Objekt was ja letzlich ausgewählt wurde ist das supermassive Schwarze Loch in der Mitte der Galaxie Messi.
Sich im Simon 80 DIYs wo von uns aus gesehen also wo muss ich auf der Erde quasi stehen um sie über mir zu.
Die ist von der Nordhalbkugel zu sehen ist ist im virgo Cluster im virgohaufen und das ist einer der größten lokalen Galaxien die wir haben.
Und deshalb auch weil sie so nah ist und so groß ist also ein großes schwarzes Loch hat ist sie halt neben dem Schwarzen Loch im Zentrum der Milchstraße,
eines der beide beiden Haupt Objekte gesehen gewesen.
Wo wo wo muss ich mich auf der Erde befinden um sie irgendwann mal direkt über mir zu haben so in etwa so schweden-deutschland Nordpol.
Der mittleres Europa ausreichende.
Okay also bei mir jetzt hier das Effelsberg Teleskop schaut irgendwann mal wirklich direkt gerade drauf sozusagen Nokia.
Yannis PK Problem genau unterm.
Das heißt Südhalbkugel viel komplett raus.
Nee.
Aber von Chile aus kann es gerade noch so über den Horizont gerade sehen so wie wir es lackierzentrum gerade noch überhaupt von von Effelsberg oder von von Spanien aus sehen können.
Jetzt auch mal rein organisatorisch wie wie findet sich denn so eine Wissenschaftler Gruppe dann zusammen also die erste Idee war da dann von Leute das Gut von wem ging es die Initiative aus überhaupt mit dem ganzen Projekt anzufangen.
Also Einzel an derzeitigen sozusagen um die auch die Technik wieder voranzubringen gab es z.b. dem Institut gab es aber,
was heißt es wurden immer jene relativ losen verbünden hat diese Idee verfolgt.
Hauptsächlich allerdings auch vielleicht mit dem Hintergrund überhaupt zu verstehen wie diese Jets die ich erwähnt habe entstehen damit besser auflösen kann man so seine schwarzen Loch nähern,
aber es gab dann vor ein paar Jahren zum ersten Mal in den Tutoren glaube ich eine größere Konferenz wo dann das J in Naama Event Horizon telescope,
total erfunden worden ist,
und wo dann halt zum ersten Mal die Idee aufkam das als größere beständige Kollaboration als solches weltweiter aufzusetzen.
Haben wir in Europa jetzt in mein Spezialfall hatten jetzt die,
Gelegenheit mit Kollegen in Frankfurt oder Luciano risola und in laiming Holland Heino Falcke eben der auch früher um,
ein Antrag beim Hobbingen Wissenschaftsrat einzureichen wo wir eben vorgeschlagen haben dass wir das extra men,
überreden ob ich muss nicht aufs rad halt finanzieren die haben auch das Geld bekommen und wir.
Haben halt mit dieser Ausrüstung sozusagen dann das Geld zusammen,
und das haben dann uns amerikanischen Kollegen dann auch nutzen können um auf ihrer Seite von der Zeit fondatioun entsprechende finanzielle Mittel zu bekommen.
Und so gab es dann Beiträge von allen europäischen Partnern aus,
Ostasien und so weiter und so kann man im Wesentlichen dann auch die finanzielle Mittel zusammen,
mal die Teleskope mit Leuten mit Ex mit mit mit Instrumenten mit auch Platten muss immer dazu gehört halt auch zu rosten und dann.
Also die quasi das funding der EU dass er der europäische Wissenschaftsrat wo auch das Horizon twenty-twenty Projekt angesiedelt ist das hat quasi den Krieg aufgemacht und dann sind alle anderen mit eingestiegen.
Ich vermute mal mit unserem Karte Kollege Frage wenn du das anders darstellen aber im Prinzip ist alles so richtigen Zeit zu rechnen.
Dass mit mir so ein paralleler Vorgang überall wurde sozusagen immer weitergegangen und dadurch dass ja damit gezogen sind wurde es irgendwann eins.
Genauer DD Rider ein Erfolg hat den anderen getriggert und so weiter und am Ende dann hat man dann hat man sich dann in in Waterloo in Karla getroffen und hat dann sozusagen der Jedi Coloration formal aus der Taufe gehoben.
War das einfach.
Also ich meine wie entwickelt man diesen diesen diesen politischen Wissenschaft politischen Druck um.
Zum einen ist es halt sehr viel Kompromisse und manchmal auch runterschlucken vom Komfort.
Das Treffen hat Ambitionen auf.
Vorstellung von Ansprüchen da es jetzt vergangene Leistungen zukünftige Leistungen sei es.
Die Notwendigkeit die jungen Leute zu beteiligen die alten Beiträge aber nicht zu vernachlässigen also da,
psychologisch gesehen ist das eine interessante Zusammenarbeit aber das ist ja im Moment Stunden und treffen gibt es gibt interessante Konstellation,
aber am Ende denke ich mal sehen alle ein dass es ohne die anderen wäre mit die anderen sind ist hat nicht geklappt hätte und auch.
Streiten gehört auch zur Kultur und solange man halt diese Streitereien halt auf Fakten und Argumente beruht und nicht halt.
Andere niedrige Kunde sage ich jetzt mal sich mein davon beeinflussen lässt,
es ist alles okay aber ich denke mal jede Kollaboration jede Partei jeder hundezüchterverein geht durch,
die deutschen interessante Episoden und das war sicherlich bei uns auch nicht anders aber denke mal die das Endziel,
oder Zwischenziel weil wir sind ja auch nicht im Ende das Bild,
zu machen das war aber ganz klar am Anfang hatten wir zuerst was ich gedacht wir würden uns,
zunächst auf das Glattzentrum konzentrieren aber wir haben schnell gemerkt dass das schwieriger ist als M 780.
Eyvallah schwarze Loch.
Unser galaktisches Center.
Unser Praktikant und alles weil es ist kleiner und da ich variabler würde es noch mit einem mit einer Scheibe drin,
hinzu kommt dass die Daten vom Südpol 6 Monate später erst ankam weil der wiggertaler Winter war.
Unterm es war klar dass sm87 da ist man nicht das einfache aber ist das Ziel war wo wir unsere Methoden sehr viel besser,
Husten und verifizieren com.
Trotzdem ist das ja wenn man jetzt diese andere Galaxien sind die ist glaube ich 55 Millionen Lichtjahre entfernt,
im Vergleich zu dem Zentrum unserer Milchstraße was war das 500 Rechnung im unsympathisch gesagt das kriege ich so schnell die umgerechnet weil sie nur so ein paar,
habe schon deutlich weiter weg das heißt dann mehr noch mal ganz andere Anforderungen ehrlich für die Teleskope oder ist es dann letztlich mit der Auflösung vergleichbar gewesen.
Das ist halt der Trick also bei der Sache gewesen das schwarze Loch ist 2000 mal schwerer und 1000 Mal,
aber auch tausend mal weiter weg und so gesehen gleich sieht das genau aus also die die die die die,
die Höhe Größe am Himmel ist Prinzip genau die gleiche das war aber nicht unbedingt klar als für sexuellen angefangen haben als Katja zwei Massen Vorschläge Messungen für M 780 in der ein Dirndl heimlich durch den Faktor 2,
das heißt ja wir hatten jetzt das Glück dass in der Tat die größere Masse die richtige war dadurch das schwarze Loch doppelt so groß als wirst wir sind im zweiten Fall gewesen wäre dann hätten wir Schwierigkeiten gehabt in der Tat.
Bilder Zeugnisse dass ich mit der Qualität machen zu können.
So gesehen hat mir bisschen Glück wird noch Glück dass das Wetter perfekt war als itscope eingeschaltet haben 2017 das kommt auch noch dazu aber gute glücklich mit den Tüchtigen.
Woher wusste man denn überhaupt dass da eins ist also ich meine es ja nur für die extrem weit weg und wenn es ohnehin schon so schwer ist das zu beobachten da kann man ja dann die Sterne nicht so genau beobachtet wie bei uns in Cent.
Richtig aber bei M 780 hat man es schon recht sehr früh gesehen dass es diesen Chat gab und die das jetzt sozusagen dass der Endpunkt dieses jetzt zeigt er immer so sauer auf dich heute genau.
Die Sumpf also hier schwarzes Loch okay alles klar.
Und da hatte halt auch vor aus verschiedenen BBM Beobachtung Villegas bewegen würde ich Darmbewegung ähnliche zweimassen Abschätzungen wie große schwarze Loch essensschrank dazwischen,
Ebene die sind drei und sechs Milliarden Sonnenmassen und nicht jetzt dann Bahncard sechseinhalb in Jarmen.
Okay also das Projekt ist dann über den Zeitraum von 10 15
Jan so langsam entstanden und man hat man sich geeinigt alles war klar man hat 18 Radioteleskope ausgesucht die alle die entsprechenden Voraussetzungen hatten und man hat dafür eine ganze Menge
neuer Ideen entwickeln müssen wie man in dir zusagen aus diesem lückenhaften Beobachtungsfeld was man ja eigentlich hatte weil
sag mal so vorstellt man dass du vorhin dieses Bild mit dem mit dem schwarzen im Karton also ich mir zu in so einer schwarzen Karton Kugel befinde und da so ein paar kleine Löcher von außen rein Pixel kommt halt immer mal wieder so ein bisschen Licht
und das ganze dreht sich und man kann ja dieses eine Objekt was er sehr weit weg ist,
von einem Teleskop vielleicht auch nur an passt nicht in halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde beobachten wenn es.
Paar Stunden Hänge und Disco am Meer.
Gut so und dann kriegt man das und dann lief es zwei Jahre anderthalb.
Naja wir haben die I hope achtung die wird vorgestellt haben sind vom April 2017 das waren 45 Tage nach einem Stück werden werden habe ich zwei Wochen geplant aber es wird aber so toll dass wir alle Daten nach vielen Tagen Kasten hatten.
Dass wir ham noch zu atmen 2018 aufgenommen da war dass das Wetter eher bescheiden und deshalb haben wir uns mit den Daten noch nicht ausführlich beschäftigt wenn zu angeschaut ab.
Unterm wir dann dann dann mussten erstmal die Daten an Orte gebracht wird vereintes gucken.
Wir sind jetzt wirklich von einer Beobachtung die wird dich nur 5 Tage gedauert hat an den dann zwei Jahre gearbeitet wurde nicht zwei Jahre lang wurde irgendwo auf eine Stelle geschaut okay.
Es waren wirklich die Worte selbst war.
War nur fünf Tage oder vier Tage aber tatsächlich diese Tools Gruppe sind so oberbuch dass das tatsächlich für ein Projekt innovativ lange Zeit,
aber da mussten die Daten erstmal ja kombiniert werden von verschiedenen Teleskopen das ist in zwei Orten passiert hier in Bonn im Keller wird fahren wir essen,
und dann in den Eisberg und hat sozusagen die Bandbreite der der Empfänger hat aufgeteilt in niedere Bandbreite einen Tage nach haystack ein Tag in here.
In der Nähe von Boston und und die Idee dabei war das im Prinzip,
die beiden Teile dasselbe zeigen sollten dass man verschiedene auswerte korrelationsmethoden sozusagen hat dass wir uns gegenseitig kontrollieren wollten das wirst richtige unabhängig voneinander machen und am Ende hat man die Daten am zusammen geschmissen.
Die volle Bandbreite und dann wie gesagt dann hat man verschiedene Algorithmen aus dieser Information wir haben in das Bild zu rekonstruieren damit rekonstruieren wird wirklich dass man halt Verfahren anwendet.
Bus geschwin Augen Ommen nicht ein richtige Antwort gibt es gibt mehrere richtige Antworten die consistency mit den Daten die aufgenommen haben.
Und da war dann eben die Schwierigkeiten die daten zu kalibrieren es gab dann Ping Pong zwischen den.
Technicorder Zion's Station und den Leuten die die Daten generiert haben.
Dann wurden der Datensatz wesentlichen freigegeben zur auswerten um das Bild zu rekonstruieren aus den Daten und auch da wie gesagt gibt verschieden Methoden da hat man folgendes gemacht da hat man,
vier Teams gebildet und diese vier Teams haben unabhängig voneinander ohne einander zu reden sich die Daten angeschaut und jeweils ein bild.
Zusatz für jeden Tag unterm weil wir eben diese menschliche,
Neigung zu sagen als soziale eilig habe das zu machen was die anderen machen und so weiter ausschließen wollten das wirklich unabhängige Teams haben wollen und nach den Ergebnissen haben wir da strikte konnektion zur Boot.
Also vier Teams an zwei Standorten oder.
Sind teilweise waren über die Welt verteilt arbeite waren sie im im im allem seinem Gebäude aber in verschiedenen Räumen.
Aber haystack war eins davon findest du dumm bemerkenswerter Name für die Suche nach der Nadel im Heuhaufen die dann auch noch im Heuhaufen Durchzug.
Ja damit den Fall warst du gerne posten aber gut die.
Und dann im Wesentlichen kamen dann alle mit mir devenir mit demselben Bild am Ende der Woche oder Tage am Ende.
Aber was hat sich denn anderen Methoden unterschieden an den andere Software angesetzt haben die andere mit.
Methoden generell zum Einsatz gebracht inwiefern war da die Arbeit unterschiedliche mit können wir vorstellen wird eine ganze Menge Software geschrieben gerade bei dieser Bildauswertung wurden die vier Mal geschrieben oder nur anders parametrisiert wie muss man sich das vorstellen.
Wir haben mindestens drei verschiedene Softwarepakete benutzt die im Wesentlichen,
dieselbe Funktion haben die sind teilweise unabhängig von anderen Stande teilweise sind sie zeitlich hintereinander entstanden aber auch die Kombination der der.
Der auswertungsschritte ist teilweise andere gewesen ZBH kavazi überlegen,
wie nimmt man aposphäre für Störung über ein Teleskop im Verkauf verglichen mit atmosphärischer Störungen Teleskop.
Außenseite Alma dass das Circus Disco befindet sich Schlüssel lernen in in Chile.
Dominiert in gewisser Weise sehr die Empfindlichkeit des Bildes da würde man das Bild verzerren wenn man da zu viel weniger ging wenig Gewicht auf die auf den sozusagen den Beitrag von von Almased.
Wie wichtig sind die Stationen die jetzt sehr weit voneinander weg sind die Zeit sich die große Auflösung bilden wie z.b. Qualität Spanien mit Hawaii Garbsen Überlapp für eine gewisse Zeit die machen gerade die,
die die die die die die die Qualität des Bildes sehr aus und alle diese Kombination die dann,
anders gebe ich dir werden können könnten theoretisch andere Bilder erzeugen und wir haben von Anfang an keine Maßgabe gehabt.
Welche Methode jetzt besser sein sollte um die Gewichte besser auszutauschen um es sie die auswendig schritte Männer zu verbinden und auch z.b. wie gesagt es gibt es gibt Algorithmen,
wo man halt man hat's nicht,
Schmutz gekappte über das nennen bis zur endgültigen Karte und das ist halt nicht aktiver Prozess die man abkürzen kann Umwege nehmen kann und so weiter und.
Wichtig ist am Ende dass wir das Ergebnis glauben und auch wäre beziehen können und das Bild war das eine dann hat man zwar ein Bild aber mussten auch verstehen gibt es vielleicht andere.
Probierte die ein ähnliches Bild erzeugen können z.b. könnte es nicht sein dass wir zwei Quellen haben die indem man da stehen und durch das Bild erzeugen kann könnten es nicht,
ein ausgedehnte Scheibe sein konnte es nicht in dir inside konnte es nicht irgendeine andere Konfiguration sein und das heißt wir haben am Darten simuliert mit verschiedenen Möglichkeiten wie man das Bild Tür red ich hätte auch erzeugen können aber keins,
passte halt so gut wie eben Interpretation die wir am Ende vor zweieinhalb Wochen hat präsentiert haben.
Die versteht das noch nicht so ganz also man man man hat diese ganzen Daten aber man weiß nicht was das eigentlich darin enthaltene Bild ist was ist so schlecht an diesen Daten das dass es nicht in sich eine Antwort lief.
Die Daten sind schon einmal die Daten sind schon eindeutig für sich gesehen aber,
was da wir die Informationen ja von dieser löchrigen Pappe sozusagen auf eine ausgefüllt aber tue Cisco,
führen wollen dieser Schritt hat im Prinzip ein Unsicherheitsfaktor muss die versucht haben sie im Sicherheits,
zu kleine möglich zu machen das hat so lange gedauert das hat sie mussten wirklich verifizieren das wäre z.b. Eigenschaften es wird nicht über oder unter interpretieren und das haben keine halt machen indem man halt.
Da diese Situation macht man weiß was man reinsteckt,
wo man dann sozusagen die CDU Beobachtung diese stattgefunden haben die Pipeline simuliert und am Ende das Resultat hat man kann man vergleichen das von reingesteckt,
und das hat man rausbekommen und so kann man halt eben die Schlussfolgerung die man gezogen hat und das Bild das am Ende präsentiert haben eben verifizieren.
Besteht das richtig ist es sozusagen.
Man hat zwar gute Daten aber man hat nicht in dem Sinne ein vollständiges Bild wie es eben ein Teleskop von der Größe der Erde insgesamt geliefert hätte soll man hat,
wenn man sich das so sagen dieses virtuelle große Teleskop was er letztlich ist darstellt,
hat man eben nur eben diese na ja diese acht Orte,
aber das dann quasi durch die Bewegung der Erde mehr sowieso Linien also quasi eben man hat
8 Linien auf so einem virtuellen Teleskop die man beobachtet oder wenn man das halt mal so auf so ein rundes Foto was man quasi dann versucht von der Region zu schießen überdenkt aber quasi so
8 Linien von,
wünschenswerterweise vielleicht 1000 die man eigentlich gehabt hätte bzw sich beliebig viele wenn man viele hätte und das hat man hat Informationen einfach gar nicht,
muss die aus den anderen hochrechnen zu wissen wie bei was nicht bei Blade Runner irgendwie wo man dann sagst du hier raus schickes Bild vergrößere in größeres Detail.
Denkt sich sozusagen den Rest dazu und diese denken ist quasi in Software umgesetzt worden auf Basis von,
Anna Mund Gewichtung,
die man dann verglichen hat womit also man muss ja irgendeinen Anhaltspunkt haben was die fehlende Informationen.
Na klar die Daten sind natürlich nicht an den Testgruppen nicht vollkommen unabhängig voneinander das ist ja der Trick dabei sondern sie haben in der Tat Informationen die in der Korrelation zwischen den Testgruppen enthalten sind und was sie machen ist im Prinzip.
Eine ein ein vervollständige die Information,
aufgrund des besten Wissens was sie haben und das Wissen kommt jetzt Form von möglichen.
Annahmen was in der Vergangenheit in der Regel beobachtet worden ist es kann daher kommen welche Korrelation zwischen den beiden Sitzgruppen z.b. stellen sich vor sie ewig wir könnten ob sie Beispiel,
Operation Ring gehst oder eine ausgefüllte Scheibe,
führt zu verschieden Korrelation zwischen verschiedenen Teleskopen und die konnte man der vergleichen und da war ganz klar zu sehen dass die Korrelationen die Beziehung der Daten zwischen verschiedenen fahren von Teleskopen,
eindeutig besser mit der Ringstruktur ist als mit dem ausgefüllten Scheibe.
Unter im Prinzip Beispiel dass ich in manchen Vorträgen unterbringen angenommen ich gebe Ihnen die Zahl die Zahlenreihe 123.
Viele Leute würden dann einfach sagen 4567 es könnte aber auch ganz klar diese Anzahl der Primzahlen 1 2 3 5 7 und 11,
was halten Sie mehr Information sie haben umso genauer wird die Vorhersage für das,
die darunter liegende Information Thailand Isaan es genauso ich versuchen halt mit jedem Teleskop mit jedem mit jeder krummen Nation gewinnen Sie mehr Einsicht darüber was tatsächlich das Bild das der.
Weil wir halt sicher gehen wollten dass wir halt keine falschen Annahmen gemacht haben die uns in irgendeiner Weise.
Ein Bild suggeriert haben das gar nichts teared da haben wir deshalb eben die verschiedenen Simulation gemacht wo wir wussten das ist das Objekt dass wir reinstecken das ist das Bild was am Ende unserer Pipeline rauskommt,
und in allen Fällen waren wir durch unsere Methoden in der Lage das reingesteckt die Bild wieder auch zu erzeugen und so mussten wir halt durch diesen Vergleich was unsere Pipeline du so sagt hat sich dich in diesem unbekannten.
Box dazwischen deine Box ist nicht wissen was passiert.
Das was aber zwischen von dem von dem Eingangsbild bis zum Endbild was wir tatsächlich sehen all das habe ich verstanden und wäre verziert mit Bildern die wir kannten dir von rein.
Also wir sind sehr sicher dass das Bild was wir am Ende produziert haben genau das Bild ist was auch sozusagen dass ich abgebildet.
Was wir am Ende publiziert haben ist tatsächlich sozusagen das mittlere Bild von allen vier Teams und,
wir sind sicher das mit weiteren Teleskopen weiteren Beobachtungen das Bild als solches auch total bestätigt wird weil bei jedesmal wird halt die Erdrotation etwas anderes sagen falls Sie wenn immer wieder etwas anderem funktionslos bekommen,
insbesondere wir hatten ja auch mehrere Tage von Beobachtung und von das Bild dass wir für die einzelnen Tage produziert haben.
Passt perfekt und konsistent zusammen mit den Bildern der anderen Tage und das gibt uns genügend Sicherheit um auch zu sagen dass Ralf richtig will.
Die Daten die 20.18 gesammelt wurden wenn dir dann auch noch mal verwendet werden.
Divera Nummer verwendet werden aber das Wetter aber sich wird schlecht dann da müssen wir schauen wie viel am Ende tatsächlich die Bildqualität verbessert oder wenn man halt mehr Rauschen dazu bringt ob es nicht hat sich zur Verschlechterung des Bildes wird nimmer.
Und wird es noch eine weitere Kampagne geben.
Wir werden gern dieses ja nicht beobachtet weil wir einfach zu,
beschäftigt war mit der Auswertung der der Christine Daten das nächste Ziel Sagittarius a stern seiner ist das dass ich will Straße,
die Daten haben wir von 2017 schon aber wir werden am 20 20 auch beobachten wir werden auch mit mir Cisco beobachten wie haben wir das,
gelenkteleskop wir haben nur immer in plateau de Boer wir haben auch große Bandbreite mittlerweile und wir haben erste Test gemacht auch zu höheren Frequenzen zu gehen,
ob man da dazu dass man auch die Auflösung.
Solitarius also das schwarze Loch in der Milchstraße soll der sozialen doch mal beobachtet werden weil man will ja auch wissen wie es hier aussieht warum nicht noch mal im 87.
Werden wir auch tun ganz klar ja ja.
Also jetzt ist eure gibt's überhaupt keinen Halt mehr egal was jetzt hier irgendwo versucht schwarz zu sein wird.
Leifkes gibt fünf bis sechs schwarze Löcher die wir weiterhin auch beobachtet haben da wird vermutlich bei den vielen wird dir momentan Auflösung nicht ausreichen und willst du Zeugen.
Kann ich nicht ausweichen weil seither verstanden 780 in drücke ich die größten Schwarzen Löcher projektiert am im Himmel Event hat sich trotzdem versuchen,
und aber die wie wird auf jeden Fall die die Bildqualität von tm87 verbessern und wir werden auch Sagittarius a stern Haltern.
Welche Laufzeit hat das eht Projekt jetzt noch so absehbar.
Die zumindest was für für das Pech Wissenschaftsrat Projekt haben noch ungefähr anderthalb Jahre funding,
wir überlegen auch natürlich ganz genau wie wir momentan eben diese Finanzierung weiter machen können.
Die Teleskope sind teilweise für ihre weiteren Betrieb finanziert das geht dann wird da wirklich darum,
Didi Didi Manpower und Logistik sozusagen zu finanzieren und mächtige der Volk wird uns erlauben die möglichen Mitteln auch zu finden.
Und vor allem sind ja auch die Werkzeuge jetzt geschärft also man man weiß dass das jetzt funktioniert man kann also sehr viel
zu solide rennen Ergebnissen kommen was wenn sie denn erwarten was durch zusätzliche Radioteleskope und vielleicht noch verbesserte Software und ihm natürlich dann auch über die Zeit mehr Kombination von mehr Daten
im Ergebnis noch besser wird.
Die Auflösung besser werden ganz klar also wir werden mit mir Teleskop mit die Bildqualität besser wenn was mehr Punkte hier Ihre Papa haben,
wir werden mit ihr großen Bandbreite werden wir mehr Photon finden das heißt wenn dann größere Kontrast bei einem Bild haben wir werden eine bessere Qualität als solches haben von Empfindlichkeit her.
Wie werden aber auch hoffentlich bei höheren Frequenzen beobachten können eventuell sodass wir auch gerade eben mit der Auflösung die Wellenlänge über die Idee des guck Durchmesser es,
die wellige verkleinern tamati die die Auflösung verbessern,
und es gibt sogar langfristige Pläne ob man das ganze nicht mit Satellitenmission halt unterstützen kann sodass man Satelliten vielleicht drei Formationsflug hat die dann,
eben wunderbare Abdeckung III Bild aber Tourist target erzeugen.
Gabalier noch fragen warum eigentlich nur Boden Teleskope zum Einsatz gekommen sind wie viele Radioteleskope fliegen in der Zeit um die Erde die im Prinzip in Frage kommen.
Ja keins also dieses Experiment.
Kein dem Wellenbereich der kompatibel wäre mit dem ungeschützen es gibt da eine russische Mission radioastron obwohl mich ganz klar Jobs den Empfang der letzten abgebrochen sie hergestellt haben,
das konnte bei einer Frequenz bis 20 kg oder ga-40 gegessen beobachten was wir brauchen 42 gegärt das heißt sie brauchen schon eine andere Qualität,
der der der der das Glück uns an Bord von Satelliten sie werden auch,
was die Datenraten angehen Anforderungen haben die nicht so trivial zu erfüllen sind aber das.
Weil extrem hochauflösend.
Ja aber die Bank weil die Bandbreite so gross ist nicht so sehr wie die hochbruch die Auflösung an die Bandbreite ist heiß wenn sie da in das Nyqvist Tempeln dann müssen sie zweimal zu schnell wie die Bandbreite sein abtasten,
und das halten dir großen Bandbreite wird begrüßt Sie Ihre Datenrate diese,
auf jede bringen müsste mit Mikronation können Sie dann nur ein Kuss Supercomputer auf die Erde machen und die Küsse können Sie auch nicht im Weltall.
Das hat Satelliten müssen sehr große Speicher haben.
Sehr große Speicher oder sehr effiziente Downing Strukturen genau.
Motoren welchen welcher Satellit wird jetzt in Fragen kommen in der Zukunft.
Hardy gibt's noch gar nicht also die müssen neu entwickelt werden aber es müsste dies müsste halt and Ride Teleskop sein dass im Schuppen im Mittelbereich agieren kann.
Okay also so ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik aber im Prinzip wäre das jetzt auch für die ESA die Nase ein weiteres Argument zu sagen ok vielleicht sollten auch mal wieder ein hochleistungs Radioteleskop in den Orbit bringen,
wenn man jetzt sich beliebigen Radioteleskop Satelliten ausdenken könnte die man so gerne hätte und man.
Würde diese Bildqualität noch hinzufügen zu den anderen 8 welchen Einfluss hätte denn das schon voraussichtlich wäre das schon signifikant weil man einfach aus dem All heraus sehr viel besser sehen kann oder
das nur ein bisschen was aus.
Wir dem Wiese turtleton gebaut wenn kann es eine Menge ausmachen alles und BB was wir jetzt überlegt hatten waren Formationsflug von drei Satellit.
Die mit unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeit um die Erde kreisen und dadurch bekommen Sie wunderbare Kombination aus verschiedenen Basis dienen wir es nennen und diese dreieckiges beschrieben haben kein andauernd ihre Form,
und füllen damit praktisch ihre ihrem Bild aber Tour vollkommen aus,
das bedeutet dass Sie gestochen scharfe also gestochen scharf mit der diem Rates lauter weil der Durchmesser für scoperte Losgröße oder ist die Erde jeden der der Satelliten im Orbit,
Radius und Weise eben die die Bildqualität sehr viel verbessert haben können Sie dadurch große bessere Dynamik haben im Bilde kann auch vorher vor einzelne Strukturen die dann sehen.
Suche glauben und interpretieren und z.b. unglaublichen Zentrum wäre das hervorragend weil.
Das ist variabel auf der Zeitskala von 12 Stunden oder so das heißt sie können dann teilweise wenn sie erlitten hätten teilweise so eine Bildqualität erzeugen dass sie sich auch,
bist nicht in den Film machen könnten wie das Plasma wirklich um das Zentrum der Milchstraße sich bewegt.
Dennoch kaltmann der Satellit hat ja gegenüber den festen Basisstation auch den Vorteil dass er eben nicht fest ist sollen über den Orbit ja im Prinzip beliebige Nord-Süd,
Position einem versichertes vorstellbar wäre so ein richtigen Nord-Süd Orbitz zunehmendes ja ja was für die Erdbeobachtung aber selbst wenn das Ding einfach so ein normalen leicht exzentrischen Orbit hätte würde das ja bedeuten dass man eben,
nicht nur von einer einzigen Stelle aussieht also quasi wenn man sich so vorstellt die anderen 18 ist Gruppe machen so Linien.
Gib mal Ragusa noch mal mit dem Sinus drüber und füllt letztlich theoretisch zumindest ja jeden. Also dich jeden funktionieren Zeitung aber man würde ja dann überall mal hinschauen können.
Genau das weiß aber ich meinte dass sie ihr Abitur im Prinzip vollkommen ausfüllen,
damals als Beispiel 20 Uhr bei der Frequenz aber von der Idee her diese Radiosender Satellit der der Russen ist auf einer sehr elliptischen Bahnen die fast bis zum Mond Abstand reicht,
was heißt da wir haben sie alle möglichen Abstände zu Erde entlang dieser Ellipsenbahn die Radio aus.
Eröffnet dann das eht Prinzip der Beobachtung und der Auswertung der Daten nicht im Prinzip auch eine komplette neue Form der Radioastronomie,
im Zusammenhang mit Satelliten weil man Erde im Prinzip beliebige Stellen des Universums auch entsprechend viel hochauflösender catega.
Ja und Nein bei der Frequenz macht das sicherlich Sinn überlegt die Teleskope die Welt benutzen auch eine Größenordnung sind.
12:15 Uhr ähm also die man damit zum Satelliten erreichen kann,
für andere Beobachtungen ist die Empfindlichkeit mehr bedeuten als die Auflösung sage ich jetzt mal so,
und da braucht man als großdisco Baby Effelsberg oder noch größer und die hieß man nicht mal eben mit dem Satelliten ins All also da werden für durch die von der Boden gestoßen und Astronomie geradeaus du mir nicht wegkommen aber als Karls Kombination
wer bestimmte Wissenschaftsbereiche macht auf jeden Fall.
Komme zum Schluss doch noch mal auf dieses Bild was jetzt entstanden ist so auf den ersten Blick.
Denkt man ja okay ich weiß es nicht genau was die native Auflösung dieses Bildes tatsächlich ist also wie viele Punkte sind da jetzt wirklich enthalten.
Das sind weniger als 100 Pixel her.
Es ist nicht nicht viel SOA.
Und man sieht jetzt so schemenhaft einen dunklen Bereich in der Mitte eben das eigentliche schwarze Loch umgeben von,
rötlich gelb gefärbten Zeug was kann man diesem Bild entnehmen.
Dimensionskapsel diese schöner Kommentar von dem internet Comic xkcd der mir das ganz gut zugänglich gemacht hat weil mal,
weil unser Sonnensystem die bitte rein gebaut hat sodass man gesehen hat dieser schwarze Bereich in der Mitte.
Entspricht ungefähr der Ausdehnung von der Sonne zur aktuellen Position,
von Voyager 1 ich das richtig sehe also im Prinzip ist es so gefühlt unser vollständiges Sonnensystem also von der Sonne bis zur Heliopause so groß ist dieser Bereich der der sich hier abzeichnet wobei das eigentliche schwarz und auch wahrscheinlich sehr viel kleiner ist,
was kann man diesen Bild jetzt entnehmen was was was bringt eigentlich jetzt alle so in Begeisterung abgesehen davon dass das man überhaupt geschafft hat ein Bild zu machen was,
Was liest man da jetzt raus.
Zu eines Denkmal im psychologischer Effekt dann Wiegert wir hatten Beweise über Schwarze Löcher Zufuhr aber das ist jetzt das Bild.
Es sichtbar macht auch mithilfe von jetzt mit mit mit Radio Beobachtung okay ich und denke ich mal ein wichtiger Schritt weil.
Die Vorstellungen der Theorie und wir konnten ja das Bild sozusagen simulieren hat eine gewisse Vorstellung was wir warten dass diese Vorstellung so.
Hundertprozentig Zusagen getroffen wurde ist schon sehr beeindruckend das ist das erste dass wir heute auf zu vermutlich schon verstehen was wir tun und das auf die Theorie als solltet wahrscheinlich wichtig ist.
Aber das hatte ich noch keinen Beweis 3tv Testtheorie als solches weil es gibt in der Tat alternative Theorien die ein ähnliches Bild erzeugen könnten,
und,
wir haben das in verschiedenen Arbeiten zu vorgezeigt es wäre so gut ist die Bildqualität zu verbessern und dann diese Feinheiten sich die sich dann ergeben zwischen Alliteration an und Alternativen Theorien,
in der Tat sehen zu können werden wir das Wortes oder zusätzliche Informationen zu bekommen,
Pfeifen beim glücklichen Zentrum durch die Bürgerbewegung von Posaunen schwarze Loch herum dann kriegen sie unterschiedliche Informationen die orthogonal zueinander sind dann können Sie es auch nein Test umwandeln.
Aber was wird denn ein Bild konkret hier sehen es ist trotzdem alles das was wir erwartet haben sie sehen eine.
Dunklen Mittelpunkt der den Schatten des Schwarzen Lochs darstellt der ist etwas Tolles in der Tat als Ereignishorizont.
Weil es um die vertun waren gehen die Zusagen sorgten Rückseite uns,
erreichen können oder nicht sie sehen diesen hellen photonenring das sind die Badesi Photonen die sich Sorgen an den dann in schattenring sozusagen anschmiegen,
dieser Ring ist auf einer Seite heller als auf der anderen Seite,
und das bedeutet dass dort Gas auf die zu sich zu bewegt,
und auf der dunklen Seite sich von ihm weg bewegt und das ist konsistent halt mit der Vorstellung einer Gas Akkretionsscheibe unter schwarzem Dach herum und,
die Größe des schwarz des Ringes oder des Zorn der Erde des Schattens sagt Ihnen die Masse des Schwarzen Lochs weil die wie gesagt in dem Jahr mit der Masse des,
Waffen doch es ansteigt dadurch können wir diese Sachsen-Anhalt Milliarden Sonnenmassen Massen,
Abstimmung Abmessung geben und dies konsistent halten mit anderen Messungen die vorher und dann damit holen gemacht worden sind.
Wir wissen also wir sehen also den Schatten wir sehen den photonenring und wir haben damit zum ersten Mal,
die grundsätzlichen Eigenschaft eines Schwarzen Lochs eines notieren Schwarzen Lochs dass sich in einer Plasma Gebilde befindet in der Tat genau also abbilden können wie wir es natürlich erwarte.
Warum sieht man in diesem Chat.
Das ist eine gute Frage es kann sein,
dass die Orientierung des jetzt gerade so ist das die dass der auf dem Bild nicht zu erkennen ist müssen jetzt schauen wo du sie ja tatsächlich entsteht kann dann das aus hattest Bilder sozusagen,
wirklich entsteht aber es ist eine der Fragen die wir hoffen nicht mit könnte auch sein dass ein Teil dieses Helden geteilte Bild ist unten Beiträge von JH.
Ist nicht auszuschließen.
Und eben davon hören dazu zu kleinen Tüten für er ausgesagt dass das wenn die neuen Daten und zu laufen.
Also höhere Auflösung könnte hier schon Erkenntnisse bringen sie das dann flexijet als ich ja sichtbar wird oder zumindest klar wird warum man ihn nicht sieht.
Was kann man also im Wesentlichen ist das Bild eine Bestätigung der bisherigen Theorien ist irgendwas auch schon kann man auch etwas ausschließen.
Um ehrlich zu sein als wir können ausschließen dass es das ist das ist keine.
Doppelte Quelle ist das ist wirklich in der Tat ein ein ein ein Schatten als solches wir könnten aber z.b. nicht ausschließen dass es jetzt nicht.
Raumzeit ist die nicht durch die Realität zu beschwören beschrieben wird diese Qualität des Bildes haben wir noch nicht aber das muss man vielleicht auch.
Ganz grundsätzlich sehen man kann nie eine Theorie bestätigen man kann eine Theorie immer nur vom Prinzip her falsifizieren,
denn die Theorie mag immer noch mit ihren Beobachtungsdaten übereinstimmen kann sein dass neuwo Wartungsdaten die Theorie dann vollkommen über den Haufen werfen,
runter wie bei den ikonischen Kollisionsrisiko die waren wissen nicht von dreihundert Jahre korrekt,
bis dann auf ne Messungen z.b. von Merkurbahn und so weiter hinzu kam die halt abweichen gezeigt,
sie können vom Prinzip her nie sagen die Relativitätstheorie ist hundertprozentig richtig schlimm oder sagen die Rötz der realitätstheorie,
diesen Test mit soviel Genauigkeit bestanden,
und diesen Test hat sie jetzt verstanden die Welt Genauigkeit ist ungefähr 10% aber es heißt nicht dass es nicht momentan nicht noch andere Alternativen Theorien gibt die sie im Prinzip die ein einziges Bild erzeugen.
Deswegen wollte ich auch gerade ab ob irgendwas jetzt vielleicht widerlegt wurde was auch noch im Raum stand das vielleicht hätte auch noch zu treffen können und jetzt sieht man das Bild dann sagt so ja nee ist nicht.
Ja es gibt sicherlich verschiedene Alternativen Theorien was man jetzt im Zentrum eines solch einen von einem 78 hätte erwarten können aber es ist halt konsistent mit wahrscheinlich einem rotieren Schwarzenau.
Also alles begeistert das Projekt geht weiter und es macht auch so den Eindruck auf mich als ob hier noch einiges zu erwarten ist also auch so.
Neu in der Bildqualität sagen aber mal auch in den Erkenntnissen die man daraus ziehen kann.
Ja ich ich ich habe letztens noch gesagt die.
Gleich wird das Bild von vom Sagittarius a Stellen im Tattoo Milchstraße nicht mehr so viel Aufmerksamkeit erregen weil es das zweite Bild sein wird.
Aber von der Physik her würde sehr interessanter werden weil wir,
Grund der Nähe des galaktischen Zentrums aber auch der Beobachtung wie gesagt durch unsere Kollegen in Garching durch die Sterne durch die Flers jemals gesehen hat aber auch auf dich auch durch ihr hättet es finden von Pulsaren herum später,
beim vielmehr,
Einschränkungen hat auf den Parameterraum dir möglich ist für verschiedene Alternativen Theorien als das Wissen m 780 haben es heißt gerade weil santarossa Sterne für Nähe ist weil wir sehr viel besser kennen wo wir auch die Masse jetzt schon relativ gut genau kennen,
können wir sehr viele bessere Einschränkungen an die Physik machen.
Weil wir da nicht nur fürs Bild angewiesen sind sondern halt die andere Zusatzinformation auch noch haben,
und so gesehen denke ich mal das Spannen in der kommt gerade erst noch das Bild ist toll und es ist eine riesen Errungenschaft und Jan Meilenstein aber das spannende was von der Physik her das kommt.
Immerhin hat Wikipedia jetzt mal was zu zeigen wenn es um schwarze Löcher geht.
Genau genau.
Das ja schon bei Schritt nach vorne ja, ich bedanke mich für die Ausführung,
schwarzen Löchern und vor allem zum Event Horizon telescope was ich in vielerlei Hinsicht für einen ziemlich bemerkenswertes Projekt halte es gibt ja nicht so viele wissenschaftliche Instrumente die auch.
Grundlegend so international auf seine internationalen Kooperationen ausgelegt sind klar es gibt die ISS aber darüber hinaus findet doch Wissenschaft immer noch sehr separiert voneinander.
Stadt und finde es eigentlich mal sehr schön diesen Ausblick zu haben dass wir noch Potenzial haben uns auf Kooperation zu einigen.
Gemeinde tut mir aber besser.
Bin Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei Raumzeit bald geht's wieder weiter einfach bis dahin tschüss.